Ooh,
the [inaudible],
the [inaudible].
Oh,
the [inaudible]
1313 ladies and gentlemen,
that's a,
it's a number.
That's very important number.
Very important.
Tell me why.
Why 1330 is important.
Yes.
Well,
we got to 13 back to back.
So it doubles the normal potency of 13 which is already a mystical number,
which terrifies people.
In the West you think it's unlucky,
but in Tibetan Buddhism it's considered a very lucky and auspicious number.
Yeah.
I was staying at a hotel in Vegas.
They have no 13th floor and I don't think they add a fourth floor either.
The fourth.
Yeah.
There's something about some cultures.
The number four is unlucky.
How many cultures do we get to influence our buildings these days?
That's what's crazy.
And what's crazier is it some point someone convinced a person,
listen,
can we just not do a 13th floor?
And they listened to him.
I'm like,
all right,
I guess we'll just go from 12 to 40
team.
Um,
shooter Jennings has it in a song.
When I check in to 14,
10 I know what room I'm really in.
Awe.
Ah,
that's cool.
Yeah.
Well are,
you know what,
that's what's so funny about it is because like that's the whole problem isn't
it?
It's like people want to pretend they're not in the 13th floor when they fucking
know they are.
Right.
Instead of just acknowledging this is where I'm at.
No,
no,
no.
We're in the 14 were 1414 called the 14th floor.
Just call it and there'll be that dude.
I went when I was in college,
we had to do service for like take,
get the degree you had to go do like service overseas.
So we went to India to Dharamsala and we taught the monks English and uh,
I was sitting with like listening over hearing a monk in a conversation with
someone teaching them English and the person's trying to explain to him how
there isn't a 13th floor in buildings in the west.
And the monk was like,
does it levitate?
Why is it missing?
How do they deal?
Use genuinely perplex.
It was like a magical thing
in a culture that forces it citizens.
If they want to run the country,
you have to believe in something that whether you're a Christian or whether
you're a baptist or Mormon,
whatever you,
whatever you are,
there's certain parts of your religion that if you just don't want to analyze
them,
just want to put them out on paper and say,
okay,
did this really happen?
Did this guy really die and come back to life?
Did is everybody agreeing on this?
[inaudible] everyone's agreeing that a Zombie,
a guy,
a Zombie,
and he came back three days later and we're cool with that.
This is a part of the doctrine,
so this is like a part of running the country.
You,
I don't think you can be an atheist in this country.
I don't think we would let you run.
It
can meet.
You have to,
I think you do have to have some affiliation with some religion or another
problem.
Yeah.
Right now it seems to be like it needs to be Christianity.
Like there needs to be like every president that has aligned themselves with,
it's like
trapped in this,
this thing that you are when you're young,
you know this thing you are when you're young,
where you're looking at the people that are older than you.
You're looking at society and you're like 16 you just starting to think,
God damn,
I'll be graduating from high school soon.
What am I going to do with my life?
You know,
it's you filled with so much angst.
Yeah.
But you always think,
yeah,
this shit doesn't make any sense.
But one day we'll,
and one day we'll be the grownups.
Yeah.
And we'll be the ones that get to make the rules and we'll go,
hey,
this is,
we're doing things all wrong.
Folks were doing things out of momentum rather than out of logic.
But that time never comes.
And then all of a sudden you're like,
you or I were,
your middle aged were middle aged men.
I'm a 51 year old man.
I'm 40 52 were middle aged.
If we're lucky,
if we're super lucky,
reality,
we're closer to death.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
So,
and we're still trapped by this thing where you,
you have to pretend,
you absolutely know,
look,
live your life.
Like Jesus is real.
Live your life.
Like you want to follow those tenants and you'll probably live a better life if
you really follow the actual true tenants of Christianity.
If you really want to believe that a guy came back to life and that only
happened once and that you have to follow this book.
Yeah.
If you don't follow this book that was clearly written and rewritten and fucked
with by people and you know that people are known liars.
Yeah.
There's,
why do we have court?
Because people lie.
What really happened?
You have to fucking get a bunch of people to sit down and figure out what really
happened.
Is this guy saying I didn't do anything,
your honor.
Yeah.
And they got prints and DNA.
And in,
in that world of known liars,
we believe a crazy story that was written when people had no science.
But we accept it because we think it makes the world a better place.
Yeah.
Man,
it's not.
And there's like so many levels of that where it's like,
yeah,
that's one obvious level that if you want to take Jesus literally,
which is you have to in certain forms of Christianity,
you're going to have to deal with some pretty severe cognitive dissonance.
You'll be taught maybe to question your instincts but then go one step deeper
and start thinking cause the real question is,
well what is real like,
I mean the eye,
there's obvious shit that's clearly bullshit.
Yeah,
but wait,
they then when you start going down you realize like you get to the point of the
self and then you start realizing that the self in this Jesus that believes in
are very similar in the sense that like,
you know,
I don't say I believe in gravity.
You would think I was crazy if I said it was to be a crazy thing to say,
look,
you know I believe there's gravity.
There is gravity,
it's testable.
It works.
But what do you always hear when people are like,
if you want to succeed,
what do you do?
You believe in yourself and it's like,
wait,
what do you mean?
Believe in yourself.
I am a south.
Why do I have to believe in it?
Right.
So that's
it's a clunky way of seeing self doubt is crippling.
Yep.
Well the self doubt,
self,
you know,
rejection.
I hate myself,
I love myself.
All these things have within it,
this concept of the South and a lot of folks,
uh,
have not spent much time really exploring like,
well what is the,
what is the self like what is my particular self?
And uh,
I think it kind of revise via via when we are Sasquatch hiring,
you know,
the cell for the many people self is very similar to big foot.
Yeah.
It's a thing that they imagined that there's signs up,
but they've never really quite seen the big foot,
you know?
Right.
But you know,
remember the feather and the trail.
It's a gift.
It means he likes you.
Yeah.
They would think that SAS
squatters were taking and leaving gifts,
taking their gifts and leaving their own gifts.
Swapping gifts.
Yeah.
And we believed it.
They believed,
they believed that the same way people believe in a religion.
You know,
I have a friend and she was a Mormon.
I've told this story before,
so forgive me if you've heard it.
Um,
she was a Mormon,
but I think it's important.
And she was a devout her whole life and then the family just fell out of it and
then they started realizing like they started going into the history of it and
then they started thinking it was preposterous.
It was right around when book of Mormon was coming out to know that hilarious
musical ends here.
It's great,
it's really good.
But she was really honest about,
she was like,
the problem is like growing up in that fundamentalist background,
it makes me very susceptible to like healers and like psychics and clairvoyants
and bullshit,
our spiritual peoples.
She's like,
I get sucked into bullshit.
And she was like almost kind of upset.
Yeah.
Well no,
not almost like she was kind of upset but like perplexed.
Like,
how do you rewire yourself when you've been trained to believe that a 14 year
old boy in 1820 found golden tablets that contained the loss work of Jesus and
then all them native Americans where the lost tribe of Israel.
I'm guy.
I mean this is,
that's the story,
right?
14 year old boy,
he had a magic rock.
He was the only one it could read it.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
She started looking into it and she is,
she's out.
Sean gone.
And that's sad too man.
Because like if you t you could take some like basic tenants,
which are true and not based on,
it kind of reminds me of like,
you know,
you hear someone who's taken Iowasca any comes to you and he's got a profound
message that came to him from some mythological creature.
A Dragon,
a butterfly has told him some kind of profound fucking thing.
Yeah.
And you realize,
oh,
the bubble machine of profundity.
You've got a bubble machine for 13,
13 upset whenever we're talking about,
let's keep it rolling.
The,
um,
yeah,
the uh,
so you don't get caught up and popping them though when you,
I know that's a problem of getting too high.
You're like done talking.
What are we doing?
Let's just pop bubbles.
Let's let the bubbles fly.
It's like for them to really like take in the basic wisdom they got from the
mythological creature.
They needed a mythological creature.
The mythological creature said something to them along the lines of you need to
love yourself more.
You need to give more to your community,
whatever the message is.
But if your Uber driver said that to you,
it wouldn't get through because it wasn't like phosphorescent it didn't have
multiple heads.
So similarly with these religions,
what happens is you do get some real transcendent wisdom that's sort of timeless
mixed in with it.
And then the people,
because they realize like,
oh my God,
it was kind of a fairy tale.
They also reject the good stuff inside of it.
And that to me is the big tragedy of any kind of fundamentalist literalist
interpretation that's being forced on people is because within that is
inevitably something great or it wouldn't be so viral like Christianity wouldn't
be here right now if there wasn't a core thread in it that had a beautiful
message in it and it makes me,
yeah,
well nicer people.
I actually had a really big conversation this weekend with a,
a very good friend about it,
about another very good friend who is very religious and we were saying like,
I think for some people it's an amazing framework and a guide to live your life.
I really do believe that.
I have several friends who are very devout Christians.
Yeah,
it's beautiful and they,
they're the nicest people I know.
And Mormons,
by the way,
I have friends that are Mormons still to this day.
I have several friends that are Mormons and there are some of the nicest people
and I don't care if they believe something that I don't believe in.
That's okay.
It's okay.
It is okay.
But I mean,
the idea that everyone is supposed to buy into stuff without questioning it is
the reason why we are 51 year old,
16 year old
dude.
I agree.
And then there's the deeper symbolic shit.
It seems to be encoded in Christianity,
whether from people projecting their own understanding on a pretty wild symbol
set or maybe it was intentional either way.
There's like a cool,
like,
you know,
the,
uh,
if we talked about this,
like if you take a cube and unfolded,
it makes a crucifix.
And like the cube represents pre big bang conditions and the crucifix represents
past,
present,
and future intersecting with Aternity.
So if you have a,
a square,
oh,
I get it.
So the,
the length,
the height is twice the width.
Yeah.
That's,
Oh,
okay.
Maybe it unfolds into a crucifix for people that are annoyed with that sound.
It sounds like a pencil sharpening over and over and over again.
We're sorry.
Sorry about that y'all.
But bubbles don't come free.
You need me to machine.
We got to hire somebody,
hire some dude.
Just blow bubbles.
What do you do?
I blow bubbles on the jre,
Bro.
I'm like fucking manly wrestler dude.
Do that man,
do that.
You have different people come in and blow bubbles and occasionally they
chairman.
Hey,
I'm going to be on the Jerry next week.
What are you doing?
I'm blowing bubbles.
Oh cool.
You're the bubble blower for the week.
You could start something that became like,
that's just what people do.
It's like,
did you get your bubble man yet?
Yeah.
I'm a classic bubble man.
I know how to do it.
The new guys,
they're too loud when they blow.
Well,
did Johnny Carson was Ed Mcmahon the first side kick.
Well
what did,
did Jack Paar have a sidekick?
I Dunno.
Yeah.
Well how many options were before that?
That Sullivan and well,
there was the other guy,
Steve Allen.
I think Steve Allen might've been the first.
Was he the first tonight show?
The second tonight show.
Okay.
Yeah,
but I think that Ed Mcmahon was probably the first sidekick and once they had a
queue,
people like,
oh yeah,
you need it,
sidekick.
You need somebody to play that part because you can bounce stuff off of him.
It's so great.
The reaction.
So much better than a laugh track.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So Christianity,
it's on one level.
Are you fucking kidding me?
It's like an I,
this nerdy part of me,
man.
When you were doing that,
Jesus is a Zombie thing.
I would really want to be like,
well technically not a Zombie.
No.
As long as he was buried,
right.
Like it's not like he did come back to life,
but through,
this is a,
there's a move in Jujitsu called the Zombie Zombie is,
is when you're in mission control and you trying to get an under hook,
you push your hand through like a Zombie rising through the ground.
So zombies get buried.
Yeah.
But I guess,
you know,
I,
I don't want to get into like comparable.
Why not?
Let's break it up.
So what is,
is that like when,
when is it just a person who's like severely disabled and when it,
is it a Zombie?
Well,
you know what I mean?
Like cause it,
well they're dead.
They're dead.
They die.
Their heart stops beating.
The doctor says they're dead.
You would be like a complete asshole if you're like,
they have this,
they have the same intelligence as humans.
There clearly there's some brain damage has happened to a Zombie.
Right?
It's a most movies.
It's a person with brain damage.
Is there any Zombie movies for their smart?
I've net.
That's just every movie.
Yeah.
But I guarantee like there's,
there's zombies movies where they run fast.
That was an evolution of the Zombie.
It started running.
The Zombie became like,
kind of like hyper violent and then,
but still,
I guess what they all have in common is that they're technically their dead.
And this is,
they don't have a heartbeat.
They're not dead like a biologist.
Be like,
the Zombie is alive.
Right.
It's just like a fungus now or something running through a parasite inside of
it,
essentially.
Yeah.
It's some kind of fungus.
Rabies.
Yeah.
Some new rabies or gut biome problem.
What was the,
the 28 days later?
Is that it?
Yeah.
That was the first one when they ran.
And that was the scary was good.
Fucking awesome.
Running Zombie was so good.
So good.
And because it was also shaky,
like when the zombies were chasing after you'd fucking panic because the screen
was shaking when it was running at you.
They were the first like Berzerker Zombie,
you know man,
all this gut buy him stuff that we're hearing now.
Like the,
the study I just read about this study today,
like they found out that what the gut biome,
what you're feeding your,
your baby affects their,
like they,
there seems to be a correlation between their gut biome and the way they act
when they're like five or something.
There are two years old or something.
Sure.
Dude.
And the autism link,
you know where they're saying they think autism might be related to like,
well who's saying that?
Jamie,
would you mind pulling that up for us?
There's a guy named Dr Peter Hotez and he was on the podcast and he is a,
is an expert in um,
autism and vaccines and diseases and foreign countries,
particularly tropical diseases in warm,
moist climate diseases.
And he was talking about how they've got it narrowed down to five environmental
factors that happen during the womb that they think possibly contribute to
autism.
Yeah.
But they don't think that it comes from something that happens later.
Huh.
This is current science according to him.
Obviously I don't know what I'm talking about.
Like for sure.
I'm not a biologist at all.
People looking at us are probably like,
how did these scientists not know this?
Barely be able to say those words in order.
Yeah.
Pretend like I know what they mean.
But I,
I listen to experts.
Um,
the mother's microbiome,
that collection of microscopic organisms that lives inside of us as a key
contributor to the risk of autism.
Some that might be one of the factors.
So it's during the womb and neurodevelopmental disorders in offspring.
Well,
it would make sense that if your body's not getting the proper nutrition and
your body is not healthy,
that whatever's going on inside of you is not going to be in the best
environment for a baby to reach 100% health.
Just makes sense.
If you're eating terrible while you're pregnant,
it's not going to be good for the kid.
But if you're eating really well and you're relaxing and taking care of
yourself,
it's probably better for the kid.
I mean,
this seems like obvious.
It doesn't seem to make any sense that that wouldn't
case.
I think the weird part of it,
to me,
it's this runs into like I ideas of free well or like autonomy in the sense that
how,
how much is the gut and the neurons in the gut and the neurons in the heart,
all the interactions
they're having with things that have different DNA than us affecting what we do
and was like,
there you go.
Long.
That's so weird because he contributes to depression.
Yeah.
And it contributes to what else?
Autism.
What other behaviors or in other words are we just essentially being driven
around by some kind of strange microscopic hive of creatures living in our shit
in some way.
Yeah.
Brian,
you know,
Brian Cowen had a pretty bad case of like of a psoriasis kept coming back nasty,
really bothered him,
tried a bunch of stuff,
couldn't get it fixed.
Went to one doctor who's a specialist,
a specialist in Gut biome and its connection to autoimmune disorders and got it
fixed.
Him Up.
Just changed up is probiotics like what he's taking prebiotics and probiotics
gave him some like heavy duty Shit.
I forget exactly what he said but it fixed it and it was basically something
going on in his gut biome and that can be affected by stress.
Yeah.
Can Be affected by lack of sleep.
There's all sorts of stuff that goes on in your body.
Like we have to think of ourselves as a s like a super organism,
like essentially like an ecosystem.
We have to think of ourselves as like,
you think of yourself as you,
hey,
it's me,
it's Joe,
it's Dunkin,
we're talking,
we're friends.
Hey what's up buddy?
But really what we are is the keepers of the realm.
Okay.
We've got a whole realm of things living inside of our body and we're feeding it
Twinkies.
And it's freaking out.
It's like you fucking moron you.
But it like would,
it feels like when Twinkies going my face,
I see your fucking knees hurt all the time.
Your back is killing you.
You have all these inflammation problems getting sits and you're 40 years old.
Like what the fuck it's cause you're eating dog shit man.
You're not giving your body anything good.
You're the keeper of the realm.
And also this is sounds like I've been thinking about is like how much data
we're eating,
which is equivalent to Twinkies.
It's like you eat a bunch of Twinkies,
your body starts hurting,
then you're just slurping up whatever the fuck on the phone.
Right.
Which I,
by the way,
I'm talking about me.
This is what I do.
I,
you know,
my bouncing around from like drudge report to Huffington report to reddit
conspiracy to read it.
What the fuck?
Zip,
Papi,
how long before you're looking at like a zit popping video and then that takes
you down into a place of like,
oh,
let's just move to animals,
cysts.
And then boom,
and then you fall asleep.
You wake up screaming.
Yep.
And that's the equivalent of getting white gas isn't it for meeting like a huge
Taco bell meal and we set a farting.
You're just just screaming in the middle of the night cause you dreamed a Colt
was dragging you into the forest.
It's like this is to me,
we seem to have not quite acknowledged that data is as much of is like a food
and that so much of the weirdness that is people are showing these like strange
behaviors.
It's gotta be because of the crazy shit they're sucking their optic nerves.
Right?
It is.
It's also the ability to affect people vague very rapidly or the to get a
reaction from someone positive or negative.
People are so addicted to that.
I watch people getting these Twitter beefs back and forth and he fucking smart
people.
Man.
A smart friend of mine who I respect greatly tried to get me to retweet
something mean that he was saying to someone else.
I'm like,
get the fuck out of here.
Like why are you,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
Like what are you doing with your time?
We get the one thing that I've done over the last week,
we did a podcast with Bert and Tom and Ari and we all looked at the amount of
screen time we put on our phone cause our,
I was proposing no smartphones.
Yeah.
Um,
my phone fucking screentime was like four hours for a day.
I was like,
what?
And I'm,
I'll lie to myself and I solo most Lhotse email and taking care of business.
Yeah.
Most of it is going through Google news feed,
looking for crazy stories of like animal attacks.
What is looking at,
man,
I watched a video today of a guy ride his dirt bike and a bear's chasing him.
I'm like,
what in the fuck?
What is happening?
Look man,
I don't want to try to like,
uh,
enable your addiction.
But honestly I think the Internet has come to depend on your wild animal attack
videos.
Like you have kind of become like a news outlet for the best wild animal attack.
People need to know,
people need to see this shit man.
Like we don't know.
I've never seen a vulture fight or rabbit or out of people do have a very weird
idea of what animals are and I think that the average person,
I'm certainly no expert,
but amongst the average person,
I have a much better understanding of wildlife because I'm out in the wild.
Yeah,
several times a year hunting.
It's a different world.
I'm no expert,
but my perception of it is as someone who sees wildlife in the wild,
they see dead ones that other ones have killed.
We came across a calf that had been ripped apart by wolves.
I mean we,
we see stuff and you realize what that is,
what that,
what that fucking forest really is.
It's this competing ecosystem of life and it's going on all the time and there's
big things jacking smaller things and there's birds snatching things off the
ground and snatch and other birds out of trees and it's happening all the time
and it's magic and you have to have it that way because otherwise the whole
population of the plant would be overrun.
You have to have your sorrow of watching the bear tear apart the font.
That has to happen because if it didn't happen,
you'd have too many fonts.
They'd be everywhere.
You'd have too many deer.
Yeah,
and you have to have someone who can take care of the bears.
Otherwise,
the bears were overrun the city where the humans live,
and we need to think about that and people don't want to because they don't want
to shoot Yogi.
They don't want to shoot Yogi and booboo.
They're our friends.
This is a teddy bear.
I grew up with a bear.
You don't know what a bear is.
I've seen a bear in the wild.
When you see the bear in the wild,
you like,
oh,
you're,
you don't give a fuck about me.
You're some weird heartless beast that is majestic looking.
Yeah.
Who runs around eating moose and deer babies.
That's what your deal is.
You eat grass and berries and you'd like to lay around your fucking cool as
shit.
It's a cool ass animal.
Yeah.
It doesn't mean you hate it,
but you've got to understand what the fuck it is.
It's not like this.
Ideally,
people don't want,
um,
people to hunt bears in certain places.
Like particularly like,
uh,
they're,
they're trying to regulate the size of a,
the amount of grizzly bears in certain parts of the country.
They're like,
hey,
we,
we need to keep a handle on this.
Like the couple people get mauled,
you know,
but people start walking through Yellowstone and get attacked.
It happens like a little bit more rapidly.
The numbers get to a certain,
I think they're like,
these things have no fear of people.
Like we could actually help the population if they hand out bear tags and people
start freaking out.
You can't kill the bears.
You can't kill the bears,
don't you kill the bed.
There's a reason why there's no fucking bears in California.
Dunkin only black bears there are fucking state flag has a grizzly bear on it.
Did you ever notice that?
Yeah.
The state flags a grizzly bear.
They earn radicating all the grizzly bears because they were eating people.
So in the fucking 18 hundreds,
dude,
there's a town,
I think it's called Levesque,
I think it's called Levesque.
It's out near like on the way to Bakersfield.
Yeah.
Lubeck.
Lubeck,
I think it's called Le Bec.
It's a town named after the last dude that got killed by a grizzly bear in
California.
Yeah.
And to investigate this thing just exuded his body and his legs were fucking
ripped apart,
like is,
you know,
needs were snapped in half and shit.
You have to destroy this tape.
I get torn apart by a bear and they killed the bear and they buried him and that
was the last bear.
There was the last bear attack.
They killed all the bears.
The reason why they killed all the bears,
because that's what you have.
Do you fuck?
Do you want to be able to walk to your car?
Yeah.
See you don't,
you don't want bears in Santa Monica.
Okay.
Shut up.
Just shut up.
We do.
We're going into their territory,
man.
They'll come into yours too.
Okay.
Stop.
Don't be silly.
We definitely shouldn't kill all the bears.
Push a kill off.
You should definitely kill some.
She kills some wolves to,
I just,
yeah,
we have to keep everything alive.
I'm going to bring back to your deck dose.
I wouldn't mind that snatching people right off of cars.
Oh,
come on.
They could be controlled.
Come on.
They can be controlled.
Put them in a,
some kind of domed,
I don't know.
It paddle down.
We never knew there were bulletproof ring them back.
Fuck it.
People shoot down on bullets.
Just bounce him down.
Hitting people on the ground
if love skin.
It's the what,
you know,
I saw something,
you know your podcast,
it's like everywhere now.
It's like dandelions every year.
You can't,
anyway,
I'm always getting suggested videos from your podcast and I saw one,
cause I've been cutting down my meat consumption.
Good for you.
And uh,
but that doesn't mean I don't eat meat.
I just want to cut it down a little bit.
And uh,
and I have been feeling
kind of enjoyable from time to time,
sense of,
you know,
that I don't know if you let yourself do this,
you probably don't.
But that feeling of like kind of bullshit,
like I'm a little better now.
A better of a person that was really like I was kind of wasn't like overt,
it wasn't like hyper obnoxious,
you know,
but just the kind of sense of like I did it,
I can cut down my beef consumption and I meeting,
you know,
I mean,
a cheese here and there and anyway,
this video popped up and it's some guests,
I don't know who it was talking about the number of animals that die in a bean
field,
like any bean field that you see.
Yeah.
So many animals just ground up and murdered and uh,
and it was great cause I realized like,
Oh of course.
Yeah.
Right.
You,
the trick I was trying to play on myself is the same.
It's the 13th floor shit.
It's like I want the world to look like a Disney film.
It's a bit,
it's a bit of a copout even saying that,
my,
my saying that because the reality is there's another solution.
The solution is organic gardening,
right.
So you can organically garden.
If you get a plot of land and get some friends together,
you can all grow enough vegetables.
So you'd have to take place in la,
which lot with large scale agriculture or if you're dealing rather with large
scale agriculture.
That's the problem.
The problem is we have to feed in just in La alone,
the greater Los Angeles area.
What is it like 20 million something people that's so many goddamn people and no
one's grown anything other than than weed.
So what do we have?
Do we have,
we have someone else to grow this fucking food for us.
So they have to do it.
Large scale.
Yeah,
and when they do it large scale,
it involves combines and those fucking things are indiscriminate.
They're just chewing up the ground and things get caught up in it.
And that's why when they clean fields,
when they pick whatever the growing,
you'll see vultures after they run the combine and see vultures circle in the
fields because they know rabbits and rats.
Jesus man,
all kinds of bugs.
I mean any kind of,
I mean I don't know if you care about bugs,
which is,
that's a weird thing,
right?
It's like vegans,
we'll get to this,
some vegans,
we'll get to this like line where they're like,
yeah,
but that's a mosquito.
Oh fuck mosquitoes.
Yeah,
they,
they have malaria.
You know,
you get to like a life form ethical boundaries.
We can't relate to a road.
Also the hilarious thing when it comes to assigning levels of sentience and then
based on that deciding if you should eat something or not,
you run into like a lot of weird problems,
which is like number one,
you're assuming a lot just because they don't have this sort of nervous system
you have.
I mean,
and who knows,
we project most of everything we are into the world and we don't really know
what the phenomena is.
But I've saw some like video of a little of an ant taking care of the ants baby.
And I don't know if you've probably heard about how trees communicate with the
uh,
mycelium.
Yes.
And like how they'll send nutrients to their children.
Yeah.
And then so then you start running into I think,
which is a really fascinating problem,
which is what if it's all alive and Cynthia and feeling for real?
What if the there is throughout the entire universe,
just as [inaudible] field of consciousness that is interacting with matter in a
way that it produces what we call life and that life is feeling terror love
maybe in different ways than we would understand it,
but it's
still there.
You know,
there's,
that's a really under consideration by legitimate scientists and fracked,
um,
Sam Harris,
his wife just wrote a book about that.
Oh really?
It's one of the subjects of,
it's called conscious and conscious or consciousness.
Sorry,
I don't remember which.
I haven't read it yet,
but I heard them talk about it on his podcast and the concept that used to be
like super woo woo was what if everything has consciousness?
Yeah.
What if everything had,
but it just can't move.
We can't express itself,
can't change its environment.
It's limited just like we can't fly and we can't swim underwater and breathe
water.
Like we were limited in our physical abilities.
But we assume that whatever limitations,
so we have like,
this is where it ends.
This is where the buck stops here.
Yeah.
Like everything that doesn't move,
it's gotta be stupid yet.
But it might not be,
which is one of the reasons why nobody wants to buy a house after someone's been
killed in it.
Right.
Like what if that house routines memory,
that was something that Rupert Sheldrake proposed a long time ago.
You know,
he's got that,
what does that very strange theory where everything is connect morphic resonance
I things from theory of morphic resonance.
He's a fascinating guy and he's like a guy who's not afraid to take some chances
and and say some really woo woo shit.
Yeah.
I think he's a Christian as well.
I love his book.
I think you're the one who like was telling me some of the studies are not so
great in it.
Yeah.
Well it wasn't that I said that is that other people would complain about that
and they can,
cause there's some,
there's some studies that apparently people lean on that aren't super legit,
like the dog knowing you're coming home on.
Yeah.
But you've got to replicate that shit because first of all,
the guy might have a loud car.
Dogs can hear shit way better than you can.
Yeah.
Like how far away is the guy when the dog starts going towards the door?
Or does the guy just come home every night and the dog has like an internal
clock and he knows,
hey,
it's five o'clock Mike wants to become a home.
Yeah.
Like if you have,
they replicated this for 1130 what if Mike starts coming home in a Tesla where
you can't hear shit?
Who knows what if he comes on?
Does a dog,
actually,
no,
he's coming.
Or is it dog?
Just hearing things.
Dog hearing adore a car.
I mean it's almost,
isn't always,
doesn't always kind of seem like the most boring possible.
A solution is usually the right one.
It's like,
yeah.
What's the most boring thing?
The most boring thing is nothing's happening.
But you're imagining the dog is somehow,
yeah.
Has It telepathic link to you?
Outcomes Razor,
right?
Yeah.
Cause our cause is the simplest,
but it's also the most boring.
Like,
you know,
these crazy fucking ufs,
I'm sorry if you've talked about this a bunch on the podcast,
but the UFO is that we're seeing that the,
you know,
navy is releasing these videos of these tic tacs zipping around and its navy
pilots.
It's not the people we interviewed in that show.
It's navy pilots who are like,
yeah,
I don't know what the fuck this is.
And I was,
I have great conversations with Uber drivers and like we were talking about it
and this guy was like in a lot of them are programmers and shit and this guy was
like,
it's probably a technique.
It's a glitch in the,
in the type of radar they're using.
I think it must be a glitch.
I mean that's the most likely a reality.
They're not seeing it with their own eyes.
They're not,
I don't think so.
I think they're just picking it up on radar.
And so he's like,
maybe it's a glitch or maybe it's like
we should find that out.
Can you Google?
Um,
if the pilots were picking it up on radar,
the pilot spotted Ufo to see if they've,
cause I know some guys have spotted things with their own eyes.
I know,
I know for sure some guys have.
Um,
I just,
I'm not sure if the dad is that,
I think
it's probably relevant to the conversation though.
It's probably a good thing that we know people listening going,
Yo,
what the fuck?
Um,
I get super skeptical.
Yeah.
I feel like,
I feel like almost like it's a plot.
I don't want to go full Eddie Bravo,
but I feel like when I see people talking about Ufos,
I'm like,
okay,
what else is going on?
What are you distracting me from?
[inaudible] is this really a big issue?
I was like,
is it really happening?
Well,
can I see it?
What do you got?
Got Nothing.
Oh,
you got like some radar.
You've got radar from one,
two pilots,
three piles.
Okay.
I believe it,
but I want to see more.
Why do I want to see more?
Like what am I?
And you'll get caught up in it and it'll chew up hours of your day.
There's a lot,
lot of those guys that we ran into on that show,
I felt bad for them because they didn't understand what had happened to them.
They'd gotten caught in this weird loop of looking for secrets and looking for
mysteries to be solved and looking for hidden conspiracies and they get caught
in that and some of that shit is real,
which is part of the problem.
Some of it you can come across the Gulf of Tonkin in the north woods operation
Northwoods.
You can come across a bunch of them that are real and raw and you can see how
they put that together.
You're like,
what?
You could see real crazy conspiring and then you can get lost and think it's
everywhere.
That's right.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean this is like,
dude,
I was just
Jamie.
Oh,
according today,
the a viz.
What does that mean?
Is that the two of you?
How about you say Ufo?
Yeah.
Are you really going to change Ufo?
Then they're like,
they have their own little thing.
They were avs.
We don't refer to us as CFOs was in my pronouns
day fees appeared at an altitude greater than 80,000 feet far higher than
commercial or military jets.
Typically fi fly initially,
the print,
Princeton's radar team with the radar.
Really high proxy or stories,
what it's called.
It's like a really high processing radar system or something.
Is it spelled prince ton of its print store?
Not his prince done apostrophes in a weird spot.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
the radar team didn't believe what they were seeing chalking up the anomalies.
Soon a equipment malfunction.
But after they determined that everything was operating as it should,
they began detecting instances which the AAVs.
I want to know what that means.
Dropped with astounding speed to lower busier airspace.
They approached the princetons commander about taking action.
He said I was chomping at the bit.
I really wanted to intercept these things.
What?
Yeah,
that's,
we have the fucking craziest people in this country.
Like there's a fucking,
there's an alien man.
I want to chase it.
I want to catch up by the tail.
The tail.
Anomalous aerial vehicles can come walk out area name for it.
You ever invented that new name is an APP.
He's an asshole.
Oh,
so actually the one who decided to call them a v.
Come on.
You know,
technically it's not an unidentified flying objects.
Did you take taking our fucking Ufo is man,
I'm,
I'm going to fight that.
What is it again?
What is the exact phrase?
Aerial vehicle.
Anomalous aerial vehicle v.
You're an asshole.
[inaudible].
It's an anomaly.
The new name for you.
Fos anonymous area
vehicle,
probably a part of $1 billion study to Fa.
Two fighters were diverted to intercept one of the strange objects when they
first arrived on the scene.
The pilots didn't see any flying objects,
but they did observe what the lead pilot commander David favor later referred to
as a disturbance in the ocean.
Oh,
the water was churning with white wave's,
breaking hoever what looked like a large object just under the surface.
Then they know it's one of the objects flying about 50 feet above the water
favor the commander of the elite black aces squadron.
It's a god Goddamn Nicholas cage movie who was a top gun program graduate with
more than 16 years of flying experience.
Described it as about 40 feet long shaped like a tic Tac candy with no obvious
means of propulsion.
It's white.
It has no wings,
it has no rotors.
I go,
Holy Shit.
What is that
dude?
You know that guy,
whoever the company is that makes tic tacs and you were like
tic tacs.
It's free publicity.
Totally protect tax is the ones sponsoring this whole deal.
You think it is?
Yeah,
man.
People are buying tictacs right now.
Listen to this.
You just say ticktack enough like you remember those old subliminal things.
He's doing movie theaters.
When you're watching a movie it,
it'd say hungry,
eat popcorn like every like 5100th frame.
They would stick like a hungry eat popcorn.
It was like subliminal texts on the sharing.
You be like,
damn,
I want some popcorn.
If you just say ticktack
tic tacs,
people are buying tic tacs right now.
While we do know that pilot's got great breath,
right?
I mean that's a tic tac man.
It's like the first time.
See a UFO either.
First thing that pops into your head is it looks like a mint.
That's nuts.
There had to be other ways to describe it.
Stocking tictacs bro.
For sure.
I have googled ticktack after he said that to her because I couldn't remember if
they were square or if they were like take,
you know
that they look to me,
I would expect a good UFO o'clock.
Yeah.
Kind of boring like Super Apple.
Like,
like if apple made a u of M.
Yeah.
It's like a clique.
Pretty sleek but don't going into the ocean part.
That's the part I liked the best because that kind of lines up with hollow earth
theory and not and like maybe like they're flying down.
Yeah.
In the,
in the center of the year.
Of course they have a base in the or why wouldn't you have a base in the ocean?
We never go there.
Do you ever fly over?
I was just,
no.
Why you fly over five hours of water?
It's just water.
Oh yeah.
Well that's that Strava APP thing.
I feel like we've talked about literally everything,
you know,
the Strava App and worrying about it.
Okay,
good.
That's great man.
I love that.
I have to think if,
pretty sure we talked about this,
the heat maps,
the Strava heat maps that seemed to show people walking under the ocean and
stuff walking.
Yeah we haven't.
Oh so yeah cause like Strava,
you know,
it's like,
um,
I think it was Strava,
right?
It's like a way for you to track your steps and some people apparently are in
some faces in the Arctic or in the ocean walking around and it showed up before
they could like turn that function off for top secret facilities.
Like the places they blur out on Google maps.
So do you think there's like a military base under the water somewhere with
submarines go?
God Man,
you know,
I want to think that,
but I'm like,
oh it's a movie.
The Mig.
Yeah,
I think it's probably a technical error,
but fuck maybe,
I mean,
I don't know.
It's like the implication of these take tax and all of it.
If you really want to like the first,
to me the most obvious one minus the churning water evidence is that it's some
kind of equipment malfunction.
It's also that they have an unlimited budget for black ops.
We don't know what that number is.
That's right.
We don't get to know.
Right.
All the weird shit they do and they're making stealth bombers and all that area
51 stuff like how much money goes to that,
like what is the number?
Let's Google this.
How much does the US spend on black ops?
I had,
I was going to bring this up in the middle of what you guys are talking a,
there's a program here that was going on the a tip advanced aerospace threat
identification program.
What's going on and had an eight to pluck you out of your money,
but I'm just going to use the AA tip.
22 million is what their budget was in 2012 and the said that it doesn't still
go on,
but apparently it does.
Louis Elizondo was still operating and he is part of,
they spent
$22 million to see if the Ufos were a threat a year.
Oh there is the to the stars academy.
Yeah,
that's,
that's Tom delonge stuff.
Yeah.
So,
well some of it's still going on.
It's all,
it's,
listen,
I am,
I'm fucking rooting for it.
I want it to be real.
I would love it if it was real.
But if you look at like the history of the great ideas,
a lot of them did come from a like weird moments,
you know,
like Tesla,
like basically had a seizure and felt like it was being contacted by something.
Like you do run into stories of,
at the very least inspiration,
but quite often innovation coming to people via like,
okay,
cheers
I transmission.
Well I've been thinking this for a long time that maybe ideas are living things
and these ideas,
even though they eat,
you think of them as something your brain's creating and maybe you brain is
creating it.
Yeah.
Maybe it uses your brain to create it so that it can manifest itself in the real
world.
So when you have ideas,
whether ideas that turned out to be art or music,
like you know,
Jimi Hendrix comes out with Voodoo child,
you're,
you are inspired by that.
Yeah.
You see it,
it gives you a great feeling.
You exchange currency to listen to it.
I mean,
just that one song,
how much money's been generated by Voodoo child.
I mean,
it's one of the greatest songs in the history of the known universe.
It's the opening guitar riff.
I've listened to that a thousand times easy.
I listened to it all the time.
Whenever I'm,
I'm like,
I need a pick me up.
That
probably,
I mean it's just,
it's a masterpiece.
It's a masterpiece of music.
And where'd that idea come from?
Well,
it came from his brain.
Right?
But where was it before it was in his brain.
Well,
how does brain cook it up and what is it?
What are these things they're just floating around that you grabbed out of
culture and how do you turn them into something that people go crazy for?
Yeah.
Because occasionally a guy will take one of those ideas and make voodoo child or
you know,
make someone else's song or make someone else's painting or,
or,
you know,
make a fucking building that's inspiring.
There's these things that come into your head.
That's right.
And you're,
you w at the end,
what they really do is they like the eggs of objects because they,
they come to your mind,
you think about them,
and then you say,
I'm going to make a fucking clock.
And you start making a clock.
That's right.
Where's that coming from?
Where the,
Oh,
it's just your creativity and it's just your mind.
It's just your imagination and well,
it's just your thought process.
Your synapses firing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're right.
We're all,
you're absolutely right.
There's no real woo woo.
Or is there,
what the fuck is a thought?
Figure that out.
No one knows what that is.
Especially where,
where are they coming from?
You,
I mean,
how many times you've read have written a joke and you're laughing at yourself
as you're writing.
Like,
where the fuck did that?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I mean,
or saying any,
sometimes like you're watching sentences come out of your mouth and you're sort
of feel like,
yeah,
every day,
all the time.
Right now,
where is the,
you know,
who's articulate again?
There's,
uh,
this,
um,
I've been studying Buddhism and any Buddhist out there,
if I fuck this up,
I'm sorry if you,
if you're more advanced or know more about it.
So I'm pregnant,
say the words wrong and stuff.
It's really interesting.
So it's like there's like eight consciousnesses,
uh,
I think it's eight.
And the sixth one is your thought,
the continuum of thoughts,
right?
So that's like,
we're,
most people hang out and they think that's who they are,
is that infinite cycle of repeating thoughts in their head.
So below that is your senses.
And then the one right above that is the seventh,
and that's what is considered your subconscious in the west.
But,
um,
so that's where all your memories are.
That's where all your,
uh,
like,
just all the shit,
you can't remember that happened to you,
that,
uh,
the,
that stuck back there that appears in people's Aarp or appears in your neurosis
or whatever.
And then above that is the eighth consciousness and that's the stored experience
of all human beings.
And that's happening.
It's like the global mind or it's Kashic records.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
the Akashic records yet.
And so basically that one drips down like a,
like water in a cave.
It drips down into your subconscious,
which drips down into your thoughts.
So when you're having these thoughts,
according to this model,
uh,
it's not necessarily your thoughts.
You're getting a kind of distillate.
It's rolling down through the global mind,
being flavored by your subconscious and then being flavored by your identity or
who you think you are.
And then,
so by the time it comes out of you,
it's got you wrapped up inside of it,
but it's a projection of some like shared mind.
It's pretty cool.
Makes
uh,
that makes actual sense.
Yeah.
No,
that sounds like crazy Voodoo hippy talk,
but it actually makes sense that we all know that there's something that we
share the,
and we all feed off of each other.
I mean,
you don't have to say this many times that I am a different person with you.
Yeah.
Like we were different together and we're different with other people as well.
I mean,
that's how human beings are.
When we,
when we interact with each other,
we have this a bonding thing.
There's a,
uh,
there's a,
an interaction thing and that's why some people are toxic for you.
I mean,
the idea that you're supposed to stay with everyone,
it's like crazy.
Like some people are just not good for you.
It's not a good mix.
You know,
you're not good for them.
They're not good for you to get out.
Yeah.
But there's something that's going on.
It's not you just as an individual.
And then when we were talking about Gut biome and,
uh,
and that as well,
you're,
you're also sharing gut biome with each other,
sharing DNA with each other,
and you're sharing the skin.
There's,
there's little Corgan isms living on your body.
You Hug people with no shirt on,
you sharing organisms.
Yeah.
It's one of the reasons why it feels good.
I bet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
I mean it's probably a great way to swap organisms to keeping spreading
you,
I mean,
yeah,
it benefits your biome,
I felt like wants to like pollinated or get out into the world
for sure.
I was reading about listening,
actually listening to a podcast,
the Steven Rinella podcasts immediate or,
and there was a guy on who was an expert in moving wildlife around how they
look.
Sometimes I'll move wolves and a certain particular areas.
They had too many moose in this one island and so they moved wolves in,
but the wolves,
there wasn't enough of them and that they were on an island,
so they all start fucking each other and they were fucking their kids and their
did.
Their DNA just was a mess.
Yeah.
Just all sorts of inbreeding and it was just terrible.
Which is also fascinating.
It's like nature's like,
no,
no.
You can't just stay around and fuck each other.
You got to get out there like nature.
Even with animals.
Nature's like [inaudible] this is not the game we're playing the game or planes,
not male and female.
The gamer pan is male that doesn't know female.
That's the game because you can't fuck your sister and you can't fuck your mom
stop if you do it a few times.
But after a while your kids are just not going to come out good.
Which is weird,
right?
Like how come if your good and your sister's good,
how come if you have sex there's a high likelihood that the kid won't be good.
There's something wrong with the child and if the child fucks the sister and
then they have a child,
it's even more likely.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
This is what inbreeding is and this is one of the reasons why you have a lot of
problems with certain dogs species.
Sure.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a weird little thing that nature's got built into it.
You can just like keep moving,
bitch,
keep touching each other.
Keeps spreading the biome.
Gotta move.
Yeah.
When am I or what you are swapping,
spit that,
keep it moving.
Have you seen a planet earth would that poor slot,
that poor Horny,
lonely sloths?
He's Horny.
I'm pretty sure it was a slot that was some kind of slow moving tree creature
and they set it up.
You know,
I don't know how much of it is real,
like how much of it is they're just filming animals and telling a story about
them.
But this law is horny.
Like bully how's out into the forest like in eight years,
like a shriek of an of a woman,
a female like and it's like,
oh fuck,
you know it's they yet this poor guy.
Look how far can you get it from where he's in the tree.
Are we allowed to show that?
Doesn't own it,
but you don't show it.
So he,
he doesn't have a girlfriend.
That's what's up.
Yeah.
And so he's a clientele of the soft world.
This is an,
it's in cell slot.
It's not because this one's actually is,
this slough has going for it.
It's like it's not staying in his apartment on the Internet.
It's,
it's leaving his tree swimming across an ocean,
climbing up another tree.
But what a dirty trick nature played on this motherfucker to have a move so
slow.
Everyone can catch you.
Yeah.
It's like nature's like,
listen,
you guys are too fucking stupid.
There's too many of you were going to have to have it so eagles you off.
So they have them so slow.
Literally no one can miss them.
What a damn dirty trick he ever see a bear run.
They run fast.
You ever see how fucking wolf or a coyote,
Rhonda?
Ridiculous.
This poor bastard,
this poor bastard is going so slow.
It looks like he's on slow Mo.
Like we're looking at the leaves.
The leaves are moving normal speed,
but he looks like he's on fucking slow Mo.
He looks like he's been eating Benzos for the last nine months.
Like just fucked up.
He's got an infinite Xanax prescription.
But yeah.
Yeah,
he's barely getting lot.
Yeah.
What are,
we must look so fast to them like to them we must seem terrifying and how
quickly we're moving about the eagles.
You know,
what does that eagle that that gets them in South America?
The Harpy Eagle?
Is that what it is?
The biggest ego on earth.
I didn't know harpies eight slots.
All they eat is monkeys and slaws cranes.
That's their favorite shit.
They snatch these slots out of the tree pitch here and they just dumped him.
Trump.
Oh Dude.
What is it?
A fight.
A fight between them.
Whoa.
Fights back.
Oh my goodness.
Oh,
that's a real young Eagle Navy fight is that although the sloths is actually
swinging at the Eagle,
imagine sorta.
He'd be like,
what are you doing man?
It's more like when someone's trying to wake you up.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
that's like a drunk guy at a bar and you're trying not to fuck them up.
Please don't make me hit you.
That is exactly it.
And the Eagle seems perplexed by it.
Yeah,
but you see the Harpy Eagle kill one because it's crazy,
man.
They just swooped down.
They're so enormous.
And one of these guys,
first of all,
Kudos to all these wildlife biologists that actually go down there and risk
their ass like that.
Boom.
Hold on back that up again,
mother fucker.
Boom.
Jesus.
That is a big killer bird.
And he just snatches that poor little guy.
Um,
but somebody had to be there to film that and there was one of them that are
watched on the Harpy Eagle,
which is a beautiful animal where this guy who was a photographer who was one of
the scientists who study and them got attacked,
the eagle swooped in and fucking took a swing at him.
She was he okay.
Yeah,
barely.
But I mean that gets sketchy when a 25 pound flying bird with knives coming out
of its feet is trying to snatch you and something that can literally carry a
fish.
Can you imagine how strong your hand would be if you could shove your hand into
the river,
snatch a salmon and pull it out with one hand?
I'm going to be honest.
It's that strong.
I do that.
That's how I fished some amazing,
I love the feeling.
Make a youtube video.
I don't want to film myself out in nature.
You know how it is as [inaudible] it.
That's my private time in the wild are they just snatch them and then they fly
with them.
They're so fucking strong.
That thing was coming after you and I think the Harpy Eagles probably even
bigger than 25 pounds,
I think 25 pounds.
Like a big Bald Eagle.
Yeah.
I'm thinking the Harpy Eagles even larger than that dude.
One of my friends told me something that has always kind of creeped me out.
It's obviously probably not true,
but like know things.
Yeah.
My two university of Bro Science,
uh,
is 11 pounds.
That's it.
Yeah.
What's the heaviest eagle.
Wow.
I'm off big time.
I guess that makes sense though,
because like a Turkey is the giant Turkeys,
like a 20 pound Turkey that the Stellar's see eagle is average weight,
15 pounds.
Oh Wow.
Philippon Eagle.
14 pounds.
Harpy Eagle 13.1 shit.
Well,
I,
why do I feel like we've done this before?
I don't know.
I feel like you were,
I thought you were right though,
but maybe it's just,
I thought I was in focus and I had to bet whether or not you looked at the way
to the biggest eagle,
I would bet $1 million.
I know what it looked at and know exactly what it is.
It's a,
I've got to confuse with an,
with an extinct eagle in New Zealand.
That was enormous.
Did they think hunted people?
And that one was 25 pounds and I was shocked that it was only 25 pounds called
the Haast eagle h a s t show.
A picture of what that fucking thing was.
Let's,
none of them verified to exceed 20 pounds,
but they think they were bigger.
Yeah.
See,
that's it.
That's where I fucked up.
I was looking at this thing and I was like,
why?
It's only 20 pounds,
25 pounds,
because you look at the size of it,
it was fucking huge.
And they really think they might've hunted humans.
She thinks that might be why the people,
uh,
I think there was New Zealand,
one of the people in New Zealand wiped him out.
And this was like before the white man came and fucked everything up.
Did you see that documentary on Falcon nearing?
No.
Which one is up?
It's this woman.
He's like,
I wish I could remember her name,
but she like goes up to I think like Tibet and they like took her in and taught
her how to like hunt because it's the way they hunt with birds and like it,
the whole relationship you have,
you sort of have to raise the Falcon from a baby and they're like connected to
it.
But it's the most insane thing to witness because it's such a remote place and
it's such a,
like traditional people,
they don't watch TV.
They don't know,
you know,
they're not like absorbed and shit like we are,
they're just out there hunting with giant birds and you know,
they figured out how to do that.
And you know,
that's,
to me all this stuff like horse ride,
any,
any human animal relationship.
When you think back to the first person who saw a falcon and was like,
I'm going to catch it and I'm going to train it to catch rabbits so we can eat.
Yeah.
How?
How,
how,
how that shit is,
I don't know if this is the exact documentary,
but this is one on it called the challenge where
that's not it,
but that's it's,
these are like in their [inaudible] Saudi Arabia.
These are like some sharpening the clause.
I'm sharpen the beak here in a second.
What are they using them to hunt?
It seems like they're having an event here,
so I don't know.
They're sharpening their beak.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
this wasn't it.
This is another version.
They're watching soccer.
They're riding on sand dunes.
These guys are driving land cruisers in the middle of the desert somewhere.
Yeah,
go pros on him and shit.
They're in land cruisers on there.
Letting go pinches the are going to get jacked.
Oh my God.
They got a room filled with pigeons or those falcons?
Yeah.
Falcons.
Well now is it?
I can't,
which one of the pigeon?
Some of them have to be pigeons,
right?
Those are pigeons.
So what is the challenge like who jacks the most pigeons?
The fuck is that.
Wait a minute.
It's called the challenge.
The movie's called the challenge.
It's a documentary that came out one of words a couple of years ago.
Really?
And it's just about Falcons,
Jack and pigeons.
I thought this was the one he was talking about,
but apparently it's not.
I want to watch it out.
Multiple little falconers sharpening the p,
the beaks and sharpen and the clause.
This is going to be your next thing.
You're going to get into Falcon nearing the next time I come here.
You're going to have a salkin some kind of like
when I'm a Mongolian dudes with the first
hat,
w the ring,
the fucking spike on the top of it.
That is the one.
That's it.
Mongolian guys driving around with a gun by started about the,
about this movie.
Oh Wow.
No Shit.
Yeah,
dudes have crazy money,
man.
They just have to figure out some way to ball so they get killer birds.
Look at those chairs.
Two birds are an amazing thing.
If you,
if you really watch them and see them in the wild,
like do their thing,
like snatch a fish out of the water.
It's what it is is a a raptor.
It's a flying raptor that just,
we tolerate it because it's small,
but we probably killed all the ones that can
to kill us.
Well yeah,
right.
They were like giant,
giant Eagle's at some point.
Pretty sure eyes on that thing,
man.
Look at that,
look at the eyes on that thing.
It has a giant.
If that was a big thing like the size of you coming at you and trying to kill
you and eat you.
First of all you'd beat totally helpless.
If that thing was your size,
you would be 100% every human being would be 100% helpless.
They,
those things are so strong it would grab a hold of you with its feet.
It would start ripping you apart with that fucking bolt cutter.
It has grown out of it's face.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
It would just,
it's just that fucking thing would be the size of a sword.
Like a Samurai sword that would just be smashing in ripping your guts out.
You'd be,
you'd probably still be alive for a second to watch it.
Take a light taste of your guts.
It would probably be,
will it
be like the size of one of shacks?
Shoes,
right.
That would be his beak size 22.
Yeah.
Like a beak.
Right.
He looked at his beak.
Big Ass shoe.
Huge knife.
Big fucking head.
Had this big,
big Gash shoe for a frown.
Caring.
You defeat its babies.
Right.
That's what they do.
Did they eat you first and puke you into the baby's mouth?
Yeah.
And they eat other birds to eat whatever the fuck they want.
Those things are always fun.
You know,
I used to find them headless in my backyard.
There was like a little bit of a war between the,
uh,
the hawks in my yard.
Yeah.
We put it in this glass fence in the back of the yard and the hawks can figure
out the fence and they fucking Dank and they,
a couple of them got k out,
one of them,
one of them we managed to save,
we brought him to like a wildlife rescue place and they rehabilitated him and
saved him.
But another couple of them died and then we would find dead.
So I think that one of them was like the dominant Hawk and he died and then
other ones just start moving into the area.
Like they were flying around my chicken coop and like little juvenile hawks are
kind of assholes,
almost like teenagers.
I was like,
what the fuck is going on here?
And then I'd find one of them with his head [inaudible] she's just like,
so like some other Hawk killed it and ripped his fucking head off and a bigger
hawk left it in my yard.
Dead with no head,
like a message.
I was trying to figure out what the fuck eat somethings head.
But apparently that's something that a hawk,
a hawk will do too.
They'll do to each other.
So it's like the equivalent of like the Mad Max putting your enemy's head on a
spike in front of your area.
Yeah.
You claim you own like all his friends get to see his headless body when you
shit on it when you fly over,
find out.
That's true.
That might be a lie.
You lie to the logs.
It's true.
But I want to find out if a hawks,
cause I believe I'm almost were very high right now,
ladies and gentlemen,
but I'm pretty sure that I read that when I found the headless bird in my yard.
Have you seen the Tibetans sky burial shit?
Yes.
Yeah.
That stuff's cool,
man.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
Tell people what it is.
Ah,
that's when you,
um,
basically,
instead of cremation,
your friends hack your body up into pieces and take it to where they're vultures
hazards.
I'm not sure which vultures scatter your body.
They descend on it,
they eat it and all that's left is bones even smash the head so that the volts
you can get inside that gets your brain all your memories.
And then I just saw this incredible documentary on the history of,
I think it was the Himalaya civilizations there because like they're
genetically,
they,
it's why the Sherpas,
they're able to help people,
like they are able to take oxygen and more,
there's some kind of split it half right.
And that at that,
that high in altitude,
but like these fucking crazy scientists were repelling down the side of these
cliff faces and going into tombs and the side of cliffs and looking at these
bones of these people where they're not sure of what their history is.
And like they'd been picked by birds,
you know,
so they were like,
oh,
okay.
They were doing the sky burial even now.
But some of them had spikes nailed into,
so I take,
they mailed them through something like,
my God,
maybe there was like a Zombie.
Like who knows what the fuck happened.
But back then they thought that,
you know,
I mean even in Western graveyard,
so you'll find spikes through what part of their audit?
I think their chest or their heads.
I think somebody killed him.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Versus post death.
Oh,
part of their ritual.
Yeah.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
Not for sure,
but pretty sure.
But that was not uncommon.
I mean we,
there's so many examples of finding like graves that have spikes hammered in
them because people thought that the body was a vampire that didn't come from
nowhere.
Do you think that there was a time when bodies just to come back to life and
that parasites dead now?
No.
I think there was a fucking time where people's neo cortex hadn't formed enough
to separate their subconscious and their conscious.
So they were like hallucinating more.
And also they were like,
they had a kind of,
they were projecting a lot of crazy shit into the world.
Also imagine when you found out you could lie like the first liars because like
there were people that would have language and then people,
once they started communicating like,
hey,
who fucking ate the tomatoes now me.
And you realize you can get away with that.
Yeah.
You could lie and say he didn't eat tomatoes when you did.
Who's the first liar?
Cause before language there was no liars.
There's no liars in the Lion Kingdom.
It's not even a concept because you,
you can't have aligned until you have communication.
Well
you could say there's the,
I guess you could say lying is the equivalent of camouflage in the sense that
when you see a,
some of these insane like uh,
animals but bugs in particular that look like flowers that look like,
you know,
yeah.
That's a lie.
It's a form of deception.
It's a form of evolutionary deception.
So yeah,
I think that like it's a linguistic,
it's a linguistic camouflage that people use to try to like navigate through
society,
not just people,
monkeys and monkeys
language.
And they lie to each other.
Yeah.
They found out that monkeys have a very specific sound they make when it's an
eagle and they have an other sound that they make when it's a cat,
like something on the ground.
So they have something for a pie and something on the ground.
And so one monkey will yell out something like,
Oh,
and eagles come on the other monkeys,
you
scattered.
And then he gets the fruit.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And then they'll,
they'll yell at somethings on the ground,
they'll run up to the trees,
they lie to each other to meet what the funniest fucking thing is,
how much we lie to ourselves.
That's where it gets amazing.
It's like,
you know,
you were talking about,
and I've done the exact same thing with screen time when you're presented that
humiliating number of hours and you've been telling friends you're busy and
you're fucking looking at that and just thinking like,
dude,
I've been like,
you know,
looking at bullshit.
But then before you do that,
you know like,
but it's my job.
You know,
I've got to kind of be online.
It's like,
no,
you're addicted to technology and because you can't stand the fact that you
don't have the discipline to stop using it,
you would rather make up a story involving some absolutely verifiable bullshit
so that you don't have to deal with the fact that you aren't in full control of
yourself
and this a non rewarding addiction,
which is really strange.
It's like when you looking at stories on like the apple news feed or something
that you're scrolling looking for something that's going to captivate you.
What does,
oh,
the apple having problems with the keyboards.
He started reading this and it's like,
oh,
you can walk away kids.
So luck call us anymore.
Like how much of that am I like you were saying earlier,
how much of that is junk thoughts?
Yeah,
he's a junk thoughts like junk food,
junk food.
You're just consuming,
consuming
and I don't think it's useless.
I think it serves that purpose.
Some of it does.
I mean in the sense of maybe not a purpose in the way you're going to be as a
human,
but a purpose in the sense of like if you apply a little bit of like mindfulness
when you're using your phone,
how do I feel right now?
You know what I'm talking about?
Like how do I fucking feel?
You realize you feel a specific way.
It's a kind of like numbness.
There's a quality of like a kind of like sedated numbness to the hypnotic state
you've been lulled into by the algorithms and there's some pleasant kind of
like,
I guess you could compare it to some like low level you fork painkiller,
but not very euphoric,
mostly just a mild numbness that is pretty good at turning off anxiety and this,
or you could at least this place your own personal anxiety.
Like if I'm scanning through my phone and I find the inevitable bad news,
whatever form it's in,
I can pretend that my anxiety is related to that news.
You know?
And then that's when you get people who are very anxious and they,
I've seen it,
I mean size who is a famous,
some person tweeted,
I'm here in this beautiful place and I can't enjoy it because of our president.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
Whoa,
I don't,
I'm not sure that's the real reason why you can enjoy that place.
I think it might be actually that you haven't dealt with the fact that you're a
vet,
you're freaking the fuck out.
Right.
That to me is like this.
The purpose of a phone.
It's very good at tricking yourself into thinking that the reason you feel like
shit is because of something happening in the world.
It's about the
bandwidth either too.
And here's what the problem with that is.
Sometimes you have like these legitimate thoughts and when you have these
legitimate thoughts,
meaning like
a meeting,
like something you're working on,
something you are,
you're like,
whether it's a,
an idea you're trying to do on stage or something else on another project that
you're doing these things,
they require your bandwidth.
Right.
And when you are always looking at your phone,
it chips away.
Percentages of your bandwidth.
10 here,
five there.
Yeah,
20 there at seven there.
And you don't think about it because Nope,
I'm still concentrating on the project.
I'm still on the project,
the project,
the project.
But really,
no,
really,
you're in two rivers at the same time.
You're in this wacky river of nonsense and wondering who got this and how much
they're getting in this divorce and who died and the Dominican Republic.
Oh my God.
Another person,
another tourist.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You know,
and you're just,
you,
if you want to look at all the bad stuff that happens amongst 7 billion people,
you have to think of all the interactions that humans have.
Yeah.
All the literally billions of interactions every day.
People constantly and occasionally one goes fucking western.
Yeah.
One goes sideways and that's the one you see on Youtube.
Jesus Christ.
This world's going to shit.
And then you watch another one and you watch another one.
You Watch infectious diseases and snake bites.
And what happens when you get net net cropsey when you fucking fleshed starts
falling off a flesh eating bacteria.
Say how'd they get that snorkeling?
And the next thing you know,
you're fucking just numb,
numb to your real life because you're taking in data from everywhere.
Yeah,
that's it.
Fuck man.
And it's like it.
Then that gets inside of you and now you're just a turbulent.
You have a turbulent self that is digested a version of the world that's only
half true.
And so because of that,
you're going to be half a person because you are not looking into like your own
whatever the fuck you are.
You know,
what are you,
what are you like that?
How much do you even think about?
What are you,
yeah,
how much time have you spent to me it's like the craziest shit that like you're,
you're,
we,
we're talking about the sex drive being this insane compulsory engine inside
every sentient being that way that I know of him.
Of course there's exceptions,
but like this is,
if you're writing a computer code,
right?
This would be a line of code,
It keeps you going,
keeps you going,
keeps you going.
So to me,
something that's fucking astounding,
Lee,
weird is,
why the fuck can people not sit still and be quiet for periods exceeding 10
minutes,
20 minutes,
30 minutes,
literally the least metabolically outside of sleeping,
right?
You're,
you're,
you're not really exerting energy when you're sitting still and being quiet.
You're,
uh,
not really doing much.
And yet if you ask,
I get asked a person if they wanted to go for a walk that was,
sure I'll go for a walk.
But if you're like,
do you want to sit with me for like 10 minutes quietly?
It's weird.
I get it.
I was like,
no,
I don't want to.
I'm not into,
no,
I don't want to do that.
What the fuck is that to me that if,
not that I believe in simulation theory,
but if I wanted to prove it or like play around with it,
the idea that we're like non player characters and some super advanced
simulator,
one of the ways I would experiment would be like,
oh,
sit still.
Why the fuck can't you sit still?
Why is it that suddenly your mind goes insane?
Why is it suddenly that you got to get out?
Why do you feel bored or crazy or fucking like over heated or anxious or
nervous?
He Productive Dunkin.
Yeah.
That's why.
That's why everybody wants stimulants.
Yeah.
Wouldn't it be more productive?
You want to contribute more people?
I mean,
I think it's,
that's what someone might say as an explanation,
but I think the fucking real reason is like people are carrying a disordered
universe inside of them.
And when they sit down and there's nothing to look at except what's around them,
they're forced to deal with the fact that actually a lot of the disturbance in
their life,
it's more related to an interior like Maelstrom of thoughts and,
and explored feelings.
And then this is just basically shaping their entire existence there,
like in every single moment,
recreating a universe of disorder and then getting really upset because if you
see this order in the world and it keeps reappearing like your friend,
he's like,
why do I get taken in by these people all the time?
It's like,
Whoa,
you could take it in by these people all the time because inside of you is a
behavior pattern that is replicating this a phenomena and you're pretending that
it's not in you to the point where it's a mystery.
It's like,
why did you know when I drive somewhere,
I'm not like,
why did my car drive me here?
You know,
unless I'm like fucking high out of my mind and should
be driving,
get nuber man.
You know what I mean?
But pull over and find a Starbucks.
A person will legitimate
Emily be like,
I don't know why I did that.
And it's like
w w w what is,
what are you?
What are you?
Are you something different if you have sugar in your gut?
Yeah.
Are you?
What?
When you're Ken DDA level hits a certain number.
Yeah,
and it starts telling you need sugar.
Dunkin.
How about a nice cold Cocacola Dunkin?
Yeah.
Duncan just crack a one one coke.
It's not going to hurt you to have one.
You're right.
I need a cake to go along with water.
Who wants to go and buy water when it's right next to the coke?
Nasty fucking waters.
Flavorless layer.
It's boom.
Spillover.
Stay live here with my water.
I want fucking sewage brown and sugar death poured into my fucking guts or a
nice IPA.
Oh yeah,
he's bitter yellow liquid.
It tastes like wheat.
Yeah.
Wait,
I did having an addictive personality,
man.
I like because it's like
it's fun to play around with it.
Meaning that when I am reaching for the thing,
whatever it may be,
that I know I shouldn't be doing in the sense of fun.
Well I like watching the rationalization that my mind starts spitting out for
it.
You know,
like,
Oh,
I'm doing this because it's like,
you know,
I'm relaxing.
You know,
it's a celebratory moment.
I feel a little bummed out and you look at like the instant way your mind tries
to come up with a bullshit story to write off the fact that you are riding
around in a vehicle that you can't control and that is not a very appealing way
to be.
No one wants to hear the pilot say,
guys,
taking my hands off the wheel.
Once you see what happens for the next 10 minutes up here,
and yet their whole lives are like that.
They was taking their hands off the wheel,
but then they're trying to make sense of it.
You know?
Like how many times do you mean alcoholic who hasn't accepted yet?
They're an alcoholic and they were like telling you all these reasons for why
you'd see my childhood,
man,
you just got to understand my childhood or you know,
it helps my writing.
I'm a better writer when I'm drunk or on and on and on and on.
And it's like,
no.
The reality is you're fucking hooked.
You're addicted.
You can't stop your hand from bringing something into your fucking mouth and you
can't deal with that because who wants to deal with that shit?
Man,
I want to be in control.
So I'll make up a story.
I'll make up a story.
I love watching your shit,
man.
That Goggins what's his name?
Oh,
he's great.
I love him forwarding laziness globally.
This guy's galloping down the road yelling into the camera and I love it,
man.
It's especially as a person who's really good at telling stories,
you know?
So like I'll fucking wake up in the morning.
I'll be like,
yeah,
there's time to go for a jog.
But you know,
I probably should fill in the fucking blank.
And it's always very important,
you know?
There's always a real good reason for it.
Like it,
but regardless,
the truth is I have yet to achieve the ability to grab that particular part of
the steering mechanism of the my identity,
you know?
And so rather than just deal with it.
Yeah,
you can't control yourself.
I'll tell myself a story.
I love that.
It's a tricky one.
Yeah,
it is.
That one.
The comfort one's a tricky one.
Comfort is the siren.
Come on,
come back to the couch.
Tongue come in and done gay learn.
But a nice cup of tea.
Tea is no vice.
It's actually good for you.
It's herbal.
Just relax a little tea.
So let's see.
Well,
ketamine,
read this.
Don't read the New York Times.
Find out what the end intellectuals think about the way the world is.
Yeah,
right,
man,
it's amazing.
I love buying things to do,
man.
I don't,
you know,
I don't sit down and listen to music.
I want to sit down and listen to some albums.
Well,
I need to because you know,
I'm just interested in music and I'm of like making
some songs and I want to become inspired.
I think a lot when I'm running in this,
one of the main reasons why are really liked to do it first thing in the morning
kind of gets my head going.
Like it gets me ramped up real early.
I have to do it like first thing in the morning because it gets your head
thinking.
Yeah.
Like it gets you,
like you're out there,
breathe in and running up the hill and you're pushing yourself,
you're tired and then thought will come into your head,
you know,
just out of nowhere and you get a strange idea.
Just pop into your head and then you start dancing around with that idea.
I'm wondering why even thinking about that now and you start thinking about,
shit,
you need to fix that.
I gotta clean my fucking office.
And you just want it and thinking about,
oh,
why did I,
I gotta call that guy back fuck.
And all these like,
it's like brain maintenance.
Like your brain's like shaking from all the pounding.
It's like,
hey,
we got to lose screw over here.
And I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I forgot I got to call that guy on.
Tighten that bitch down.
Yeah man that I this,
this is what I love about meditating and uh,
that's something I am,
I finally have figured out how to do regularly and uh,
I love it.
Oh often doing every day.
That's awesome.
Every day.
How much time?
20 minutes.
How much time do you jerk off during the meditation?
Oh God man.
You know it varies based on the weather.
It's so fucking
Barain made you horny.
Just getting set and don't want to beat off.
She's here when it's raining.
It's just like I come faster but then like if it's windy I can't get up.
If there was a movie about someone who just became a fucking NYMPHOMANIAC when
it rained out,
I'm sure that happens.
Like as soon as it rains out it's like fuck a good book.
If there was,
if that's how,
I mean you think about humans,
how we're affected by things like depressed when it rains up
or you know,
we don't like I did now again,
definitely I just feel like saying this shit cause you get attacked by
scientists are smart.
People are like,
you don't know what you're talking about.
I know.
I don't know what I'm talking about.
I don't either.
We're talking about a hypothetical world where people get horny when it rains.
Well yeah,
but I want to take it into the sun man.
I want to move it to the next level,
which is like where does solar minimum now apparently,
which is the sun is not very active and so the sun
also scientists and you're telling me this,
it's the craziest shit man.
The son freaks me out.
Not just like the fact there is a son,
but the solar observatory,
the shit that happened up at that solar is ever Terry.
I'm high.
I can't even say observatory.
Observatory.
Turn the turn.
The bubbles on please.
The bubbles.
What's happening in the solar observatory?
You heard about this shit to happen.
There's this solar observatory that just got fucking shut down.
All of a sudden like the black helicopters came in and like,
anyway,
I don't know what happened there,
but down the sun is at a solar minimum right now.
Look,
we have to fucking get through a paywall.
You saw me.
What is this?
Oh you to,
Oh,
I'm tired
guys.
Alright,
continue.
What do they want?
Fucks UFO sightings.
Nasa Soho space probe spots.
Giant alien disc shoot out of hollow son.
What?
That's not a rule.
This Express Duncan.
That's like,
that's the hardcore scientific staff.
Take me to like something.
Yeah.
Who is,
uh,
is the express like the daily mail did they make who makes stuff up like the
acquirer or someone?
This was the newspaper wasn't daily and Gizmodo.
That's my total solar eclipse will pass right over a space observatory.
Oh
Wow.
So have you really not heard about the solar observatory that got shut down?
I'm surprised pretty.
The pictures.
Will you look that up?
Just solar observatory.
Shutdown black helicopters.
Go back to that photo real quick.
Before we do that,
we'll do that real quick.
Sorry.
Asking,
Lord,
is he?
No,
no,
it's okay.
I'm very sorry.
But look at that God damn
photo.
This is photo of the solar eclipse and you see all the rays of the sun.
By the way,
imagine if these were little multi verses.
Each instance.
Are we out of juice?
This,
this thing just devour bubble.
We got run out of fucking bubbles.
We ran out of bubbles,
right?
When you're about to talk about the multiverse,
look at the rays coming
you off that thing.
I mean,
what is that?
Is that what that is?
That although solar rays,
is that,
what the fuck is that coming off of that thing?
Those are called Zeit Gar spirals.
Those they'll fuck you up,
man.
Yeah,
they're deadly.
They're like definitely one of the most dangerous thing in face.
Yo,
that's what,
uh,
Robert Schoch,
the geologist from Boston University thinks and did the ice age.
His theory is that it was a mass coronal ejection that caused lightening storms
like rain coming down,
but lightning all over the earth.
It's a very common fear.
And preppers.
Do you watch preppers?
I've watched it a couple times,
but it freaks me out.
The got,
everybody's got a reason.
Like I'm building this shelter because I'm afraid of hurricanes.
But yeah,
you hear like just the liberals,
the hurricanes elegant,
the sun comes up a lot.
Like I should.
Well,
I mean,
look,
we can only exist in a very narrow temperature band.
That's what you have to think is strange.
You know,
we have a temperature band.
What is it?
It's from like fucking 20 below zero to like 150.
That's all we got this,
we got this weird little spot.
This piece of shit die already.
God dammit.
How much,
how much juice does it use?
Well,
it's got a little observatory in here,
uh,
not observed
reservoir,
tiny solar observatory and it's getting shut down.
It's um,
hmm.
You know,
the,
the narrow band that we can live in,
we're so fragile as an organism that we should be terrified of this giant
nuclear explosion that's a million times bigger than the earth.
Sure.
That we need to stay and need.
We need to keep,
I mean,
imagine relying on that thing to make sure the temperature is in like a range of
plus or minus 100 degrees.
Like what the fuck are you talking about?
That's crazy.
Crazy,
crazy requests.
Well this is like,
you know,
I don't believe it man,
but I love hollow earth theory.
Here we go.
Oh yeah,
baby.
And like bubbles.
If I,
if aliens were watching guys like terrestrial aliens,
not interdimensional aliens porn to make the distinction.
If terrestrial aliens are watching us,
I think they would be like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
Y'All live on the outside of the thing.
You got to go in.
Why don't cause mountains fall out of the sky?
You're going to build your whole inside collapse.
Well,
I'm saying like if you dig deep enough,
maybe there's a way no air down there.
Well that's,
you got to get air down there.
I mean,
it is,
when you think about it,
it's like we've built this fragile civilization using this super advanced brand
new inter connective technological matrix that is dependent on satellites giving
gps coordinates to keep everything running.
And we're right next to a ball of fire that has historically from time to time
blasted so much fucking crazy shit at our planet.
There was a time that it caused like telegram wires to spark.
It's like if that shit hits the satellites,
they're going to go out.
Oh,
the power grid goes down,
everything goes down.
It's not conspiracy theory.
It's happened.
Yeah.
And sometimes it cools down and it enters into a thing called a grand solar
minimum I think is what it's called.
And that's sometimes starts ice ages.
Like there was a mini ice age that happened not that long ago where the sun
theoretically just,
I dunno,
it stopped being so active and then 1719 1790 yeah.
Yeah.
And that,
so this is like a reality that nobody seems to really like think about.
I mean that to me is the funniest thing when everyone's fighting each other,
we're all like furious at whoever the fuck is.
Like.
Nobody wants to accept like mountains fall out of the sky,
the sun from time to time burps fire so bright that it causes fires to break out
on the planet.
And then all the other shit we don't know about.
You know,
just the stuff we don't know about like that.
If we could talk then
yeah.
1,200 foot asteroid could crash into earth because NASA missed these small
details.
Oh Geez.
Less than a week old story.
Jesus Christ.
I don't need to see this NASA fucked up.
Yeah.
Well they haven't been getting any money,
Jamie.
You think that's why?
Yes.
Trump is diverted all the funds to the space force.
No.
The truth is they,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
would they even tell us?
I mean that's,
no,
no.
You don't think no let it hit you don't think they'd be like,
no,
where are you going to do?
They wouldn't warn us going to hit.
It's going to hit.
You know,
Neil degrasse Tyson says,
we're like decades away from being able to divert it decades.
Decades.
Yeah.
If something's coming our way,
some civilization ender,
we're fucked and he,
this is not conspiracy theory folks.
There was an article today that a,
I put it on my Twitter that I read about hyenas.
They used to have hyenas in Canada up until the last ice age.
There's hyenas in fucking Canada.
Dude.
Like this whole thing changes all the time.
At the time,
there was a mile high sheet of ice up there.
Two miles high in some places.
That's right.
I was just in Chicago,
man.
And you look out at the Lake Lake Michigan.
Yeah.
She's amazing.
You look at it from Chicago.
Whoa,
whoa.
That was a fucking glacier.
That was a,
there was an ice.
She didn't have a melted.
Yeah,
that's how it got there.
That's the room,
the remanence of the melted ice sheets.
The whole fucking thing was under ice.
Yeah.
There's a place in Wisconsin where my friend Doug has a farm Cazenovia
Wisconsin.
That's a part of what they call the driftless area and the driftless area is the
places where the,
the,
these glaciers didn't come down and crush flat everything in front of them.
That's why you go to the Midwest.
It's fucking flat.
Yeah.
Flat as this table.
Why is that?
Because the fucking glaciers came down.
Just smush that mother fucker.
Just,
that's how it came down.
Like this giant mile high wall of ice just destroys everything in front of her
as it rolls across the landscape.
But it didn't hit this one area of Wisconsin and it's a,
or it didn't hit it as hard because you've got all these beautiful hills and
valleys.
That's pretty dope.
Whoa,
that's beautiful.
Oh Holy Shit.
Isn't that crazy man?
Crazy that that happened 12,000 years ago.
Right?
So this is,
we're not talking about something that's a long time ago and then boom,
that shit melts and becomes an an interior freshwater ocean.
Ms. Essentially what it is,
dude,
it's like our entire civilization is living the way like a middle aged
alcoholic.
He's starting to realize all the trouble they caused leaves but still debt going
to keep drinking.
Kind of like,
it's like if you look at like our whole species as one thing,
it's like right now we're dealing with like the same thing maybe smokers deal
with after a lifetime of smoking.
Like suddenly health effects are starting to happen,
right?
We've had like a,
a a nice run,
but now we're starting to get a little bit of payback for all the decisions past
generations have made.
We've got fucking radiation pouring into the ocean.
The ice caps are fucking melting.
And then on top of that,
the majority of us can't just can't deal that we either say fake news or we say,
uh,
now that are going to be dead anyway.
Bad.
Yeah.
Yet that,
those are the two things.
Because the reality to me like this fucking amazing thing about being a human is
that we are like a technological hive that has built itself around a planet
using the materials of the planet to make technology.
And we're still at the point of hive life where we're pretending there's
different bees when we're all the same fucking be,
you know,
it's just some of some of us are running weird operating systems and we can't
accept the fact that it's like,
listen,
we're a fucking hive of super advanced primates that are all living together in
a hive because that's the overview effect,
man.
We're astronauts talk about flying over and looking down.
It's like it's all the same.
The cities are mostly all the same and all the structures all look pretty much
the same.
Of course it's a fucking hive as schizophrenia.
Hive where pieces of the hive or like,
yeah,
over there we got a bomb.
That part of the hive because that part of the hive is different than us.
So that part of the hive wants to hurt us,
you know,
it pheromones being released,
not by queen bees but by influencers.
You know,
like the news,
the media blasting out this data pheromone that gets us ready for the wars,
gets us ready for the violence,
tries to justify,
rationalize it.
And then there's other weird new like little mini queen bees popping up,
releasing weird Fairmont's the influencers,
you know,
they're like,
some of them are making people dress a certain way,
fashion or whatever.
Some of them are making people freak out.
Some of them are making people more calm,
but we're dealing with the fact that we're all starting to wake up,
right?
We're all going to have to wake up to the fact that we're all the same thing
living in a,
uh,
in a hive.
And that if we don't come to that epiphany,
an individual,
I mean we're probably fucked.
Like we figured out a split the atom and we've got,
uh,
the,
the technology as it's coming in,
it's making the ability,
it's like,
I'm sorry,
please go ahead.
And collectively we kind of know,
but
it's very difficult for everybody to act.
Yeah.
Right.
Collectively we kind of know that we can't do things the way we're doing,
but they're going to do it.
What are we going to do?
Well,
he's going to drive that truck with the smoke coming out of the bat.
We'll fuck it.
I don't want to fix though.
What am I going to do about this?
What do I do?
What do we do?
Who's in charge?
Who's in charge and what do we do?
You're asking me.
No.
Anybody.
Nobody.
Nobody has the answer to that.
Yeah.
I think you gotta like get pragmatic.
I mean,
I,
there's that thing John Paul Sarte said,
and I'm not throwing bullets thought once said,
but it has stuck with me ever since I heard it.
Which is whatever you do,
you give the planet permission to do,
you give everyone permission to do so.
To me,
what's helped me like live a little less in a,
in a crazy like asshole way.
I mean,
aside from him having a baby is a realizing that,
oh,
if I can't stop,
you know,
using as much plastic as I do,
the world's fucked.
If I can't stop any kind of activity that I look into the world and think,
man,
why are people doing that?
Then the world is fucked because if you,
you know that fuck,
I'm sorry man.
Can I ran about as quick story,
do you mind?
I'm sorry.
You know that Gandhi story?
Which one?
The one about like this and then this,
who knows?
Could be fake news.
I don't care as a parable,
it's cool.
But this woman brings her a kid to Gandhi and says,
I can't get him to stop eating sugar.
And Gandhi says,
come back in a month.
And uh,
she's like,
all right,
comes back in a month.
And God,
he looks at the kid and goes,
stop eating sugar.
And she's like,
why did you wait a month for this?
And Gandhi's like,
well I wanted to see if I could stop eating sugar first and you know,
before,
I'm like,
yeah.
Yeah.
So it's like,
to me the,
yeah,
it's cool,
right?
There's a listlessness in the world because everyone wants to be heroic.
But people are wanting to act on the global stage while neglecting the,
their,
their home,
their family themselves.
And it's frustrating because you,
why wouldn't you think that?
Cause it seems like we're being,
like,
you're seeing the big,
big scale of things,
but it's like personally,
when I fucking finally it clicked,
man,
I can't change anybody else.
Like I'm not going to make anyone do anything.
I'm not gonna make anyone meditate.
I'm not going to make anyone do this or that or do anything because everyone's
doing their own trip anyway.
Man.
Who the fuck am I to say what our life?
But that's part of the problem,
right?
It's the people trying to get people to behave a certain way.
That's we're,
we're experienced a lot of that right now.
Yes.
Yes man.
And it's like,
the thing is that's the impulse is noble,
but it's unfortunately,
it's like trying to build a fucking second storey house when you haven't built
the first story,
which is like you need to like get your own house in order and then maybe
there's some teaching,
but usually by the time that happens,
you don't,
you're not,
you're on a talker,
you know.
And so to me that has been like a real exciting thing to realize.
This Jack Kornfield says this,
I'm sorry if I've said this before,
tend to the part of the garden you can touch and um,
that's it.
So it's like,
to me it's just a big relief.
Number one,
you can't do shit for anybody else but yourself.
Number two,
you don't need no one.
None of us know.
We don't have to impose some moral thing on you.
But there is it one actionable thing and action anyone
can take which is amoral,
which is find out who you are.
That's it.
Find out who you are,
who are you really,
what are you,
explore that shit.
Right and then see how you start changing.
I think that's a real pragmatic solution to all this stuff and it actionable to,
and it's like you want to find out who you are by,
you know,
rubbing Manet's all of your Dick and letting your dog like get off of you think
that's a true exploration.
Go ahead work for me.
I'm enlightened now.
That's the way,
I'm just kidding.
Speaking of Ozone,
oh Jay's on Twitter.
I saw that shit.
Do you see the one guy who
made a parody video of his welcome Twitter world?
He made this weird dad video.
It's so strangely,
what's the word?
Apocalyptic.
No disingenuous.
Strangely disingenuous.
I thought it was like,
he's like,
he's acting again but he hasn't acted in forever.
And also maybe he's suffering a little bit from the football injuries cause
there's a struggle.
I'm,
I am very sensitive to people that have been hit in the head a lot of times
struggling to talk cause I look for it.
I see it in people that don't want to see it.
And it's scary and we all talk about it.
Like people that work for the UFC fighters,
trainers,
it's people who do kickboxing.
We all,
everyone talks about seeing certain folks starting to slip and some folks will
start to talk about it,
about themselves.
You know,
they're having a problem.
That's what I got.
I was listening to that.
So like a little Twitter world.
All right.
I didn't take that Oj Simpson.
Yeah.
I'm going to go.
I can dispel some of the bs the people have been saying about,
um,
about me with no accountability.
Yeah.
Plus I'm going to talk about sports and politics.
It's like this weird acting job that he did.
It's creepy,
man.
Whoa.
It was weird.
All that.
Yeah.
So it was a weird moment,
man.
I,
that's a cool,
that,
that thing that happens to people who've like done shitty things where instead
of just saying like,
yeah,
I fucked up.
Oh,
I have a chance say that.
You can't say,
yeah,
I killed somebody.
Right.
Well you can.
But if you do that,
you're going to suddenly,
and there'll be,
I think for anybody who's done,
she thinks the moment you just say it,
you get to be standing again on the real ground,
like the real terrain instead of like the bullshit world he'd been living in.
But when you decide not to do that,
then you do have this like,
well it's like the uncanny valley.
Like you have this like android quality to you because you're not reflecting
reality.
You're reflecting reality after you put lipstick on it and sunglasses and combed
his hair,
put some perfume on out of a nose job,
got its ass,
got asked him plants and that's your fucking realities is super plastic.
Like someone who's been getting plastic surgery for years.
And so you're pretending that that's your existence.
You see it man,
when like people are getting sentenced for killing people and they're like the,
the look on their fucking faces,
like so confused because they have created this valley in between that person,
the person they are.
And,
and you know,
it's,
they've split in half essentially,
and they can't deal with,
that's why so many people have murdered.
People will say,
I wasn't there.
I don't remember.
It was a dream.
I didn't know I didn't do it.
And Gacy I should be a,
I should be sentenced for running a funeral home without a license.
He was saying when he was out of town,
people were bearing kid dead kid bodies under his fucking house.
You know,
Eddie minute you met him.
He tripped himself enough.
Really?
Absolutely.
Because otherwise you have to deal with the fact that you are a murderer,
that you killed fucking,
you strangled fucking kids that you dress like a fucking clown,
you know,
and,
and like killed kids.
Like it's so unpalatable to deal with that shit because you're just a crazy
lunatic who is out of control.
So you'd rather make up a story.
Usually it's conspiratorial.
Somebody was like,
somebody was like,
hey man,
you know where you can bury those kid bodies.
I think gacys out of town.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
man,
isn't that fucking crazy?
It's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I know.
And that's the thing people voice said about Ojai,
that it's almost like he doesn't even believe he did it now.
But the problem with that is there was a fucking Emoji that he tweeted at this
guy,
you know,
he had a direct message with this guy and he had like 16 knives and he said he's
going to cut them.
Like if that's true,
if he really did send that,
if it's not Photoshop,
that's not bullshit.
You imagine getting a DM from Oj cause you made a parody video.
She's God.
Cause like while,
I can't guess what he did was he put ogs video where he was talking and in the
background he had someone screaming,
help call the police,
help,
help.
And so then Oj sends him his direct message,
allegedly,
who knows what really happened.
Who knows.
But if it did,
dude,
I would fucking,
I would like find a cave somewhere.
I'd want to move to the Hamartia is I can't,
I couldn't deal with it man.
Hello Twitter world.
I'm just,
you know,
cause he could get you like you could get you if you want it to.
I bet.
Yeah.
I mean most times you have left.
He's 71 years old
after he DMZ disappears.
You know,
people like we don't know where he is.
Norm Mcdonald tweeted at them.
It's hilarious.
Norm said,
hey juice.
Um,
I just wanted to tell you that through that video.
I know the golf course that's behind you so I could figure out where your house
is and I wouldn't do that.
But somebody else might.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That was hilarious.
Nor Mcdonald's.
So funny.
These are the best.
I'm trying to get him to do a podcast.
I was trying to get him an Adam.
You get to do a podcast.
I don't know what he can do though while he's got this Netflix deal and these
shows is,
I don't know where it's at.
I don't know if he has a contract,
but he should do a podcast.
It's so goddamn national.
Travis.
See did he doesn't have a podcast.
He's so fucking funny.
Well isn't his show.
Kai is kind of like a podcast,
like it has that,
but he hasn't been doing it.
Oh.
And they don't want him doing interviews and stuff.
It's like it's a little tricky cause he said some crazy shit.
You know norm says crazy shit and he said some crazy shit like,
like if you,
it's about someone saying something that will you believe that you'd have to be,
you'd have to have down syndrome.
Huh?
Like he thought that would be better than say you'd have to be retarded
and they put like what the fuck?
Dammit.
That'd people got real mad at him.
I think it was on the stern show.
He's just,
he's just a treasure.
Okay.
Joe,
I'm sorry to like I want,
I like,
I thought I had all these questions for you man.
I was like guess lame to ask my questions on their show and it's not in the
moment like we often do,
but I really do.
I know you've probably been talking about it,
but I wanted to hear your take on deep fake cause like that fucking deep faker.
You really bothered me.
Like it set off like a whole series of thoughts in my head that like of all the
futuristic shit that freaks me out from us.
Well for someone like you or someone like me,
it's easy for them to do it because they basically got a library of all the
sounds that we can make with our mouth.
And so they put it in a database and then they can get you to say words you've
never said before and in order that you've never said them before in a way that
you can kind of distinguish.
For now,
I kind of can hear that it's fake,
but it was me talking about sponsoring a hockey team fills all chimpanzees.
Yeah.
And teaching chimps to play hockey,
we sounds exactly like something I would do.
And um,
it's,
it's close.
You know,
I mean,
they had one a few years ago that they did with Ronald Reagan where they had a
fake speech and this was way,
way before the Internet.
And someone had pieced together a fake collaboration of a bunch of different
Ronald Reagan's speeches and then use them with sound editing and turned it into
a whole statement that he never gave before.
And then the White House went on television and showed how they did it and
showed on the news all the different speeches that they pulled from.
And this,
the actual sentence is where they pulled from.
They showed it to you.
So there could be no denying someone,
I forget what it was.
Maybe it was the Russians.
Was it the Russians?
Yeah,
of course someone had done that but I don't know.
I don't know who did it.
I don't remember.
But it was interesting cause I was like,
Oh wow,
they can do that.
But I thought,
you know,
think about how many times Ronald Reagan has given speeches.
You just take,
listen someone with painstaking detail,
mark down all the words in those speeches,
put them all in some sort of a multi loop cause it's,
you know,
you'd have to go like to Phil Spector's house and they have the old school real
to real.
Should sound recorders piece that shit together and splice it up and then
release it.
Pretend that Ronald Reagan is trying to start a war with Iran or something like
that.
I forget what it was.
Do you remember the premise?
No,
I don't remember the premise of that,
but I remember that the recording,
I don't know.
I kind of remember it,
but it's a foggy memory man.
It's pretty wild.
But this is like
to me,
fuck the sun and all the things to worry about.
This shit is really intense man.
Like you know about the hostage,
the fucking weird hostage.
I found thing people are doing where they're like you get a phone call from the
phone number of your wife and you answer it and it's like we've kidnapped your
wife.
You don't someone freaking out in the background.
They're like send us money or she's fucked.
And like they've been right now they've been doing is they've been,
you know,
someone will say let me talk to her and they just hand it to some lady.
Yeah.
He's like,
you
think,
oh my God,
it's her.
I'll give you whatever you want.
People have been sending them money,
you know.
And like when you consider like what happens when deep fake technology
intersects with just the ability to like call people from spoofed numbers and it
suddenly if someone gets your phone number list,
they're going to be able to call your friends is you and record conversations
where it is.
They sort of dredge up,
you know,
who knows whatever they want.
Maybe they want to blackmail you,
maybe they want to get money,
maybe they want to embarrass you.
That to me is like so spectacularly fucking weird that we're going to end up
having to have passwords that we tell each other away from our Alexis,
which is like,
listen,
if I call you and I'm seeming strange,
you know the,
the password is like go for 69 otherwise it's not me.
You know,
cause that's gonna that's a reality.
I mean just look what people are already fucking doing with spoofing numbers.
That's fucked up man.
And like that,
that aspect of it.
And also just like supply and demand.
In other words,
there's one Joe Rogan,
right,
right now.
But if an AI starts duplicating you and improving on you,
like,
and I'm saying,
you know,
five or 10 years,
no offense man,
but maybe an AI could like turn you twice as smart,
you know,
make you like whatever,
who knows what,
and then suddenly you're no longer in demand in the sense that once the Joe
Rogan AI package goes on the dark web or makes its way into wherever people are
going to just be able to download you and have conversations with you and make
video.
Don't know that to be is the the,
so what are the most bizarre realities that we are entering into is one where
you're going to go on youtube and there's going to be a video of you,
looks like you,
sounds like you,
but it's like 50 times funnier than you,
50 times cooler than you,
50 times smarter than you because it's an AI pulling from the Internet.
It's just you,
but better.
And no one's gonna want to watch you anymore.
Cause they're like,
I want to watch,
I love the railroad gun,
but I want to watch the Rogan who's brain is functioning 50 times the speed of a
normal human brain.
Because that guy,
wow,
that's either going to take over,
will rise all obsolete.
Were they?
Yeah.
Of all of us.
They're going to be like invasion of the body snatchers.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right man.
And that's not,
I mean I'm saying even if,
let's say it's 20 years away,
that's still too fucking soon.
Hundred let's go crazy then.
Yeah.
We're going to be basically like sort of drowned out by multiple versions of
ourself with exponential intelligence.
Yeah.
Well that was my concern when I was talking to Kurzweil about downloading your
consciousness into a computer.
I'm like,
what's to stop you from making multiple copies if you can make one copy.
Yeah.
Like what's,
what's to stop you from being like,
tell me some fat guy with a little dick was a real asshole.
Wouldn't hack into the system and infest it with copies of him.
Yeah.
That just overwhelms everyone else's data where he is omnipotent and he is
literally the ruler of the realm that he exists in.
Yeah.
Cause he's figured out how to hack into the grid and take over.
Imagine you think you're going to be in heaven,
you're going to enter into this virtual reality,
but look,
you're going to get to what?
Fly Dragons and have sex with beautiful women and eat fruit and this fat guy
with a little Dick,
he acts the system and then everybody's going to suck his dick.
And everywhere you go is a version of him is trying to get you to suck his dick.
Come on.
It's fucking people's ears as he's holding people down five,
six of 'em on a person by just fucking you from every angle by,
that's what he created in this.
I mean that's what a computer virus is.
Sure.
Fucking everybody,
right?
If you think about that the most,
there's a lot of viruses.
I don't know what,
how,
what percentage of viruses,
Jamie,
you'd know this are not financially motivated.
There's gotta be some viruses that people create just a fuck.
Sure.
Right in the old days for sure,
man.
I mean,
I think,
yeah,
they were just there to fuck up your threes or computer fuck up you.
They didn't have,
they weren't worm.
They weren't grabbing data to use it against you.
They're just like,
you know,
shutting your computer down.
It'd be a dick.
Yeah.
Or making it say weird things like you know,
real basic.
The old viruses in the days of AOL,
remember those man there are cool.
They were like scary,
but not like today where they like shut down the power grid until you send
somebody $1 million worth of bitcoin.
Oh,
you have to completely remap your hard drive.
Completely.
Re Upload your operating system just kills every of the only way you got to kill
the operating systems.
Swipe it clean.
Start from scratch.
Sorry.
It's all cooked.
Yeah.
All your work.
Fuck off.
Gone.
Gone Man.
Just like this fat guy with a little Dick than everybody.
Hundreds of them.
A Sea of I'm running at you.
Pulling on their half our decks.
Yeah.
Well,
the Ha,
there's a story got around this weekend about a Samsung.
TV's having viruses and,
and then you being able to scan it for a virus.
There's like a program on it that allows you to scan for viruses.
And then Ted,
I guess today Samsung deleted that tweet.
Oh Great.
People are pointing back to this being an act.
The weeping angel program or the CIA could use your TV to listen to your
conversations.
And they are doing that and they're recording it.
Being Angel.
What a great name.
Why doesn't the CIA started dating the fucking navy?
UFO weeping angel.
Why do they call it that?
Why do they call?
What is that?
That's why.
Why do they have to bring angels?
Is that Satan?
Is Satan a weeping angel?
Is that what they're saying?
Like what the fuck is that?
And weeping angel.
That's weird,
man.
That's fucking weird.
But like,
you know,
the implication that they in your deep fake that they sent out to the world was
it already happened.
You know,
they're like,
how do you know this hasn't already happened?
In other words like how do we know we're not duplicates?
How do we know we're not one of an infinite number and array of like,
you know,
versions of ice that are being populated all over something.
Some
server somewhere could be,
well that's the thing about the simulation theories that one day we,
if things keep going the way they are,
like then I was going to bring this up when we were talking about people like
looking at cities and looking at the grids and looking at the high like what is,
what are these cities doing while they're spreading and the being productive.
They're making things and they make me better things all the time.
Well,
if they're making better things all the time,
like what are they interested in?
While they're interested in computers and CGI and artificial intelligence and
artificial life and,
and they're all definitely moving in some sort of a,
a greater technological dependency.
Like we're pretty dependent now,
but it's going to get greater and greater,
right?
Yeah.
We'll get more and more.
Whoa,
one t one day,
they're going to have a reality that isn't tangible in the sense that without
this system you wouldn't be able to experience it.
But it will be a reality once you're in the system.
Once you're in the system,
you will feel your elbows on the oak desk.
Yes.
You will feel the sweat on your palms,
you'll feel the sunglasses on your nose,
you'll feel all those things.
Yeah.
So who's to say that that's not real?
Well,
that can happen one day.
If they can create an artificial reality that you cannot discern from the
reality that you're currently experiencing,
how do you know it hasn't already happened?
Right?
You don't.
And you know,
some super fucking people think that we should keep open the possibility that
that is what we're operating under her or that the stability and the rigidity of
the dimension that we exist in is not nearly as firm and not nearly as permanent
as we like to think it is.
Right.
Which is one of the reasons why psychedelics is so exciting.
And so,
uh,
there's,
there's so,
there's hope.
Okay.
They're transformative,
but they're also,
they're valuable,
yeah,
they aluminate the possibility of others,
of other things,
other dimensions,
other life forms,
other,
other levels of consciousness of other ways of interacting with each other.
Especially my mom.
I kind of,
all of them,
all of them.
That when you take the guy a transformative dose and you experienced some weird
thing where you're like,
oh,
this is possible to like,
this is like a whole nother way of existing.
Like who's to say that if,
if if human neuro chemistry,
right.
If that's what's causing depression and elation and dopamine and Serotonin and
all these different wonderful things,
it's caused Melatonin.
It's all these different things that happen when you're sleeping.
And then the psychedelic ones like the DMT W who's to say that we have to exist
with this mixture,
right?
Who's to say that life with a thicker mixture isn't also possible and might be
going on around us all the time.
Like,
cause there might be these porous sort of entryways into these other dementia
calls that are consistently open and closed and they're constantly around us all
the time.
But when we're,
when we're just in straight normal consciousness that we experience without
perturbing it with alcohol or pot or psychedelics,
we want to think that this is reality.
This is rigid,
this is it,
but maybe it's of reality.
Yeah,
it is a fuck load of them.
Maybe when you make decisions,
you enter into different ones.
Maybe you're constantly shifting the one that's around you and how you interact
with people.
You mean like your decisions or the way you navigate through the multiverse?
It's entirely possible,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I want to say that too many times.
It is a thing.
If you,
if you,
if you just think about how little we understand about consciousness,
about happens when you die,
what happens when you sleep with how little we know about what,
what is going on when you're communicating with people,
what is going on when you're interacting with people,
what did we,
are these fucking ideas coming from?
Yeah.
Are these ideas little life forms in a non observed state?
Yeah,
man,
Bro,
you take it off the glasses.
You're getting crazy.
I just realized I didn't get to look at your beautiful eyes show.
It was enjoying this.
We did it for hours.
Um,
star bright in here,
but the,
you know,
man like that when you start the
thing you're saying about psychedelics kind of like showing you a different way
and that when you're in a base reality state,
your people spend a lot of energy trying to imagine a solidity that isn't really
there.
Yeah.
And like,
you know,
as I've been taught by some people that you know,
you if you start breaking it down just logically,
uh,
for example like uh,
you know,
your past for example,
you ever do that,
spend any time with your memories and you realize like,
well now your most vivid memory,
whatever it may be,
you can't really taste what you're eating or feel that euphoria that you were
feeling or the fear of you are feeling or whatever.
Cause if you did,
then you,
the memory would not work for a person who was trying to like stay alive cause
you,
and if you just remember the last time you got punched in the face you would
feel it.
You know.
And also if you could remember tastes you wouldn't be so inclined to eat because
you could just go back and think to the last chocolate bar you a and you would
taste it.
Or obviously if you could remember orgasms as they are,
you wouldn't really need to fuck.
You would just think about having sex whenever you had it and you would come,
you'd feel like you were coming.
So if we look at memories experientials there's a lot of like senses that aren't
gratified by memory.
And also if you look at them from the visual field,
even the most profoundly quote photographic memory is wavery at best it's not
HD.
It certainly wouldn't be a four K TV.
It's got to kind of like a quality to it that is just,
Oh you know,
flow.
It's a little transparent.
So then when we think about the future,
obviously that doesn't exist.
Like it's,
there's just no future.
That's nothing is outside of this point in time.
And so then now you've basically just from a simple analysis of your memories,
which a lot of people imagine that's who they are.
Like there a snake in the present moments,
the head and the back is the past with all their memories sort of intertwined.
But you realize like no,
that's really foggy approximation of what happened at best and you really don't
remember most of the shit you did anyway.
Like you don't remember what you ate three days ago,
10 days ago.
So then you realize your whole path,
the thing you've been using to define yourself as a person,
you barely remember it and the parts you do remember it,
they're not really clear.
So that's gone now.
That's death.
You're dead.
Anything that happened before this moment,
that's death.
It's gone.
There's just this for real.
That's not now.
There might be some neurological and coding,
but there's no past.
Forget it.
It's why people are to get really good at things,
you know?
Well,
you mean it gives them a sense of stability.
That's why if you have a physical skill,
like say you could do gymnastics.
Do you know Chappelle Lacey?
No.
Funny.
Funny up and coming new comic.
But he was a world champion cheerleader like uh,
like crazy skills and he's jacked.
Built like a linebacker.
Well,
don't let go.
I don't know.
Football.
Defensive back running back.
Anyway.
Stud could do a backflip.
Just jump through the air and land and you're like,
why?
Like what the fuck?
Yeah.
Right.
When he does that,
he knows that he had those experiences.
You learn how to do that.
He has a skill,
has a very unusual skill.
Yeah.
Like,
like a break dancer.
They know they can do that crazy shit with,
they can hop around on one arm.
Yeah.
Their feet up in the air.
Criss crossing and going into the Lotus position.
How many people can do that?
They can do that.
They could do it.
That defines their existence in a way.
Yeah.
Because now they're not just living in the moment.
They also have knowledge.
They Chapelle crazy.
Yeah.
Fucking nuts,
dude.
There's one that he sent me,
I'll send it to you,
Jamie,
where um,
he flips a girl through the air,
look at that shit.
Or you can do flips a girl through the air and then catches her on one hand and
presses her above his head.
Crazy.
Dude.
It's fucking bananas.
Bananas,
banana.
So he knows that he can do those things.
He knows you can do those things because he learn those things.
Yeah.
Those things carry him.
They defined you.
They give you extra value.
You can hold onto them as a support,
like a security blanket.
And it's crazy world.
Hey,
I can play the piano,
mother fucker.
Let me get on the piano.
I'm going to show everybody at the party.
Um,
Dube head.
I think
the is that you don't,
oh man.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
man.
He's just sing the song tonight.
Oh,
in the MOU from melody.
I exist.
I am [inaudible].
I'm real.
I'm trying
give something.
Put China spray something out in the world.
The people like the smell,
so they come closer to my flowers,
right,
man.
Ah,
you deserve more Dunkin.
You can sing.
You should sing all the time everywhere.
Oh thanks.
You just saying,
oh you shouldn't even talk.
You're an angel.
I know.
The way you sing is amazing.
Well I trained for five years.
I just like to sit around and listen to you.
Have you ever been in a party where somebody breaks out a guitar and actually
sings a song like animal house style?
Well,
uh,
that scene is amazing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I have.
I'm trying to remember.
I think if that has happened it's one of the memories I,
my brain is like,
we're not going to remember that we're not carrying that with us cause it would
much cause it's holding a hostage situation.
Let's face it.
Like once they sit down and start strumming that shit.
If you're the guy who walks out,
look at that fucking hater.
He can't play guitars,
egos being challenged when the reality is you're like,
I don't want to deal with it,
man.
I don't want to deal with all the levels of having to face the fact that you
fired a neuron that made it seem okay.
That in the middle of a party where nobody was playing music or maybe music was
playing.
You turn it off.
Dude.
I know of a guy who in the middle of a football game pause the game to show his
acting real well.
That's just lunacy.
That's it.
No,
that's someone who's like sick.
Paused the game.
Just a broken man or woman paused the game to show an acting reel.
Shambling how my new real man,
you guys gotta check this out.
The game can wait.
Seriously guys to game Kuwait.
He did a great job.
You're going to get great pleasure out of watching me fake.
Watch me fake now I'm a detective.
Okay at me.
I've got a gun,
dude.
It's,
it's,
it's a hunger cause it's,
this is,
this is the quiet,
I mean it's like you're talking about back flips.
It's like,
imagine this self is so
the self is so imaginary that we have to exert to the point of doing back flips
to give us a sense that the self,
my spears,
we think it is.
It's,
that's right.
Like you don't have to exert to be sitting in a chair.
Gravity does it for you.
There is no energy that needs to be exerted.
But how often do you hear someone saying,
what a great day either.
There's a great day,
great day,
amazing,
but why are you saying it?
Like why do you feel the need to exert this much energy to announce to me it's a
great day.
Hmm.
Could it be that you're not quite certain it's a great day?
Could it be that there's a feeling in you that something's a little amiss,
so you gotta like paint reality with words to make it okay,
this isn't a ghost story.
I'm not going to die,
is it?
Or is by saying it's a great day.
Are you putting out this hope that I'm going to go,
wow,
Dunkin,
such a positive guy.
He's amazing.
Yeah.
When he says it's a great day,
I feel it is a great day.
He puts me in a better mood.
Thanks,
Duncan.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think if you look at,
anytime I've done that shit,
I'm too high.
I'm getting paranoid and I'm trying to get some affirmation from a friend,
you know?
That's usually the feeling is one of me.
Like you know like when you're around someone you realize like they want me to
compliment them right now.
They are,
and you feel that like when they,
when they open the fucking doors and a spaceship,
you temporarily open the doors of the infinite vacuum of that worst.
Yeah.
When they'd get upset.
When you don't compromise.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's the craziest.
Duncan have known you for a long time.
You'd never complimented my art.
Oh Wow.
Sandcastles or my life and I know you don't,
you know,
you don't even say they're cool.
They're fucking great man.
Okay.
You're saying castles are incredible.
I mean,
you know,
it's just weird that I have to tell you.
Yeah,
I know.
I'm sorry man.
You're great.
We worship you will,
where should be forever.
You'll be known forever is a great sandcastle maker.
That's a funny thing.
It did also add to that that the very same sort of person who is intent on
getting you to acknowledge their fucking sandcastles,
which is a great description of it because no matter what
you're doing,
it's a fucking sand castle.
Look at those glaciers.
They're using whatever you're doing for get it,
but then you have these people who are on top of this sick need for a person to
affirm their existence by complimenting their ridiculous sandcastle art.
They also want to leave a legacy.
That's funny.
Shit.
It's like they,
it's not enough that we worship you now.
You want generations of people to worship.
Hmm.
That's a big one for people leaving a legacy.
That's a big one for artists.
Big One for athletes.
Athletes want to believe records that no one will break.
That's right.
Leave a legacy behind.
Man.
This to me,
this is like being in a dream and wanting to leave a memory of yourself in a
dream.
You know,
like you want your,
I want my did people I met in that dream.
I want their kids to be talking about me after I wake up.
It's like when you die,
you know it's done.
We don't know exactly what's after this,
but you're pretty much recycled,
man.
There might be some karmic momentum.
There might be some kind of like some residue in trays all over again or your
Peter Scratch.
I often gotten that yet
the whales to sells three and then you just keep doing in infinity to get it
right.
That loop going.
Keep that loop go and like where we're essentially in some kind of like Karmic
sanding mechanisms,
right?
If you like life,
why wouldn't you want to do it again?
There's Enlighta.
It wasn't if you like life,
do you like life?
Yes.
If you found out that this was what you were going to do forever and ever and
ever and it's going to repeat itself over and over and over again,
would you like,
no,
it's pointless.
It's pointless now and it's finite.
Is it different if it's pointless,
as infinite?
Is it different?
Is Different?
Don't you just enjoy life?
Is that the key?
The key to just enjoy life?
That's where it's ironic when you pick up a skill,
like learn to play the piano or learn to do back flips,
or in my case,
learn to do martial arts is that you actually become a better person through
learning how to do something.
Cause it's hard.
So you learn about yourself,
you learn who you are,
you learn the bullshit that you tell yourself,
like to really get good at something.
Like if you want to get that good,
it's doing backflips man,
you gotta fucking actually practice.
You can't bullshit yourself and really don't need to come into the yard to do
with that guy can do.
You got fucking practice.
And by practicing,
you put yourself through this rigid exercise routine and you do it correctly and
you exert yourself and you have to do,
it requires 100% of your focus.
And in doing so,
whether it's playing piano or throwing kicks or whatever the fuck it is in doing
so,
you understand yourself better.
Yeah.
So,
even though I radically,
you're kind of defining who you are as a person and you're giving yourself like
extra clout because you're,
uh,
you're the fucking man at Dunkin,
a ball into a net.
I'm the fucking man.
Everybody watched and watched assholes.
Yeah.
But by doing that,
you actually learned how to become a better person too because hard because it's
hard to do.
And then if you can figure it out,
the puzzle will help you get a better hold of all your human skills because it
would be a difficult thing if you really want to get good at something.
If you really want to leave behind a legacy,
like you have to achieve a level of focus and a level of intense thinking and
concentration that most people are just going to Peter out before they get to
that spot.
Sure.
I mean,
that's what I love about what you're talking about is it's a force field in
between you and an elite like fuck the Illuminati.
The force field of the learning curve separates every single person from a
terrain that cannot be reached with money.
Like,
I don't care how rich you are.
If you want to learn how to do a back flip,
you might be able to pay for great trainers,
but you still got to do the fucking work.
You got to do the work 100% so this is cool because you now,
you enter into a realm that is inaccessible by money,
is inaccessible by power,
but is weirdly generally accessible by anybody.
In other words,
the only thing keeping you from whatever the fucking thing is you want to get
good at to show yourself that it is possible to leave the reality that you're in
and enter a completely different reality.
Because yeah,
for me,
if suddenly I was in a world where I could do fucking back flips,
might as well be an alternate dimension.
Like if I got home and did a back flip in front of my wife,
she would,
it would be that.
She would probably be more amazing if I like levitated.
You know what I mean?
She'd be like,
what the fuck have you done where you've,
you've
reality must be fragmented.
So it's like,
in other words,
the you,
wherever you're at,
whatever the thing is that you,
you are,
there's always this interesting mountainous,
rugged terrain separating you from a completely different universe where you can
do back flips,
play the piano,
play the guitar,
whatever the fucking specific thing it is you want to pick up.
That's kind of cool.
To me it's like the only thing keeping you from it is consistency.
It's not money usually unless it's like you want to be a falconer year or some
shit.
You got to get a falcon,
but in general,
you know you could like,
that's why I live about that.
Goggins man.
I like that guy like you.
It's weird how much he impacts me even though I'm still fucking,
I will look
and I like,
I like it.
At one point I thought someone was running next to him filming him before I
realized it was a car and I'm like,
I want to know is filming God steady?
Yeah,
it's,
yeah.
I realized I was disappointed because I thought there was an anonymous and
anonymous.
Yeah,
he's running,
getting no credit at all.
It's probably his fiance,
but you know,
that's to me that's kind of why I love that because it's like it's equal access.
No one is being barred from the learning curve.
Now the specific learning curve you might be getting barred from,
you know what I mean?
Like do you want to Mow Guan
it's 8,000 fucking dollars.
Okay.
Like you're not going to get that.
You're not going to learn to play that if you don't have that kind of money.
It's a mug one.
It's like something that fell out of his space.
Ship that I'm obsessed with that like it's just this beautiful synthesizer man.
It's like
fill out of a spaceship.
Dude.
I have to Piss so bad.
Can you talk to Jamie and then I'll let you pee pee too.
Right?
How did you know man?
Cause I could tell shared mine cause I'm wriggling you're moving a little funny.
Yeah.
Who wants to be first?
You want to first?
What a Fucking Gentleman You pee first.
Cause if you announced it you got to go I think on your way.
Okay,
I'll be right back.
great.
I was like,
look this up.
The mood one.
Yeah,
forget it.
What do you where you have a mode right now though,
right?
I got to sub 37 but um,
the,
you know,
the Mo one is um,
polyphonic and the sub 37 is monophonic so he can't really play chords on it.
Uh,
but it's not just that,
it's like the whole,
I mean it's a colt around these sense because they did figure out a way to dial
in as perfect specific,
beautiful sound that once you even,
I mean if you like playing music,
which you know,
I just do is that you play with toys.
I feel like I asked you to see it like a year ago.
What you just play for yourself most.
Like you just like to sit in a room and turn off the light or put on mood lights
or whatever and just make your own music instead of listening to what people are
making for you to listen.
Yeah.
Well I mean I like both,
but I just,
I like the,
with Cynthia musical synthesis,
I really,
there's like a weird kind of philosophy behind it.
Which is not only do you not have to worry about making,
you know,
whatever it is,
I'm an album or something,
but it kind of like allow yourself a break from imagining you even need to be
musical.
Just like,
you know,
you give kids pots and pans and they fucking thing it together.
It's just fun.
A friend of mine,
uh,
Billy Mays,
the third,
he's actually the son of Billy Mays.
He travels around playing music as a on a,
on an under a name called infinite third and he does a thing called mouth
council,
which sounds like almost what you're doing,
where he takes a loop pedal as a microphone.
He starts,
it makes us sound,
and then he passes it around to the next person.
It's like you have it,
you make a sound.
Then Joe would make a sound and then by the end of the eight person,
nine person thing,
he knows how to use the pedal enough that it becomes basically a song,
almost like a song.
It's a drip assist,
the droning loop.
So it's not really,
yeah,
no,
it's probably,
but it's,
it's almost like this and he does very similar things with,
by himself.
It gets real cool.
But it's just like,
like what you're saying though,
it's not music to listen to necessarily got structure.
Uh,
it's,
it's to have on in the background sort of and like,
yeah,
whatever you're doing really used in lots of ways.
It's like,
yeah,
I think it's just like,
you know,
you could be whoever this is is clearly a great what it musician,
but also you can just enjoy dialing in these like insane alien noises for no
reason other than you just are trying to make sounds.
And that's it.
I mean,
it really is like you take that and combine it with most any psychedelic
marijuana and what you have there is the ultimate fucking spaceship essentially
that you're just like,
you don't need,
we're just talking about,
it's not,
the idea behind this is you can get good at it and these things are so precisely
dialed in that if you want it to be like the uh,
you know,
they teach you music just from interacting with it.
But also there's just this visceral like pleasure of making noises through
sense,
you know?
Yeah.
I often think what would happen if you got sucked into this world like
physiology.
That's me.
Evil on me.
Ricky,
Bobby,
I would like to put that evil on you.
That'd be fucking cool.
You start playing them more often.
Playing quake had to swear off of it
again.
Again,
I now hours a day hours.
When you asked me,
you texted do I play quake and I got the same feeling you get when you have a
friend who's like gone sober and they're like asking you to look,
get a drink.
Okay.
Yeah,
man.
I had a problem playing hours a day and I just went cold Turkey.
I went,
stop.
What are you doing?
I'm going to go take note.
I'm going to Piss [inaudible].
How long does it take you to Piss with that?
Soon on?
This is,
depends on where I'm at.
Like in a combat situation.
Diapers.
Yeah,
but in general it takes like 30 minutes or so.
Okay.
But I'll be back.
All right,
great.
I wear diapers and combat.
Excuse me.
This whole episode,
1313 was a hundred percent Tompkins idea.
I get this text message from,
hey man,
can I do episode 1313 just do them.
Figure out the window.
I'm like fuck yeah,
you can,
I,
I need,
I need to do that with you.
I noticed that.
I was going to ask if you guys have planned it.
Yeah.
Well we planned episode six six six that was also his idea.
That was the last time he wore a pope outfit and I wore my white NASA outfit.
I have a white NASA outfit and an orange one.
That was awesome.
Um,
but yeah,
1313 is a real thing.
But we aren't really on 13,
13 cause this like podcasts on the planes in they're 70 MMA shows if I
companion.
Yeah.
Those,
those are hundreds of them.
That's a crazy number.
Well you guys are talking about,
I didn't want to interrupt the conversation but this uh,
as sort of just come out to help with the deep fake stuff.
Adobe's announced that they've got a tool that they've,
I don't know how well it works right now that just show a picture so they don't
show it in action or anything,
but it's a way to tell if a photo has been manipulated with Photoshop.
Keep that off.
Those Instagram hoes.
Nobody knows that.
Anybody who looks like,
you know,
I mean do those,
this,
some Instagram people literally look like cartoons.
Like do you look at their photos you like,
are you what you're not a professional on a picture.
Yeah.
I've never fucked with the APP
face.
Face tune I think is a lot of people use,
is that what the yearly like you can just draw some guys where you do it.
Yeah,
for sure.
They do.
Their whole face is blurry.
It's like,
what's happening here?
I had to put my glasses on,
look closer at it.
I'm like what are you your spray paint?
Weirdly rosy cheeks.
Yeah.
Your spray person.
We're talking about Instagram filters like Ai.
Um,
Adobe's new AI tool can spot when a face has been Photoshop.
Yeah.
So saying that,
keep that off the Instagram hoes.
Yeah.
You got like a,
if no idea that this person who is actually a CGI,
she's like,
Oh I've heard of that.
Yeah.
People didn't know her name.
Yeah,
well they're saying they're going to do that at the models now you know they do
that with houses.
Like sometimes you look at a picture and you're like,
wait a minute,
is this real?
And like under construction currently will be completed summer of 2020,
like Whoa.
So this is not a picture of a house.
This is a CGI house but sea got shadows and the floor has texture.
I mean it looks fucking real man.
I've seen some real ass looking houses and that's,
you know,
real estate agents use and that shit.
Why wouldn't like a clothing designer have like the perfect body to compliment
their perfect clothes,
you know?
Yeah.
That,
um,
I'm sure you've shown this on your billion times,
but yeah.
That you're talking about the AI that just generates people.
Yeah.
That shakes fake models.
Beautiful.
Perfect people in every way.
Yeah.
In every way.
I agree every way.
Perfect.
In fact,
it's a,
it's funny that some people trip out about people that look really good on
Instagram and they say they're,
they're giving off unrealistic body images.
Hmm.
And that this is something we should stay away from.
Unreal.
It's like that guy from vox was doing that about his,
he got everybody's hating on him cause he was saying that about gay thirst traps
that they put out unrealistic body images and that you should think about them
the same way you think about cigarette ads or,
or liquor ads.
Yeah,
exactly.
What,
no,
they're in shape.
Unrealistic is such a crazy thing to say when you're actually looking at a real
person.
Unrealistic body expectations.
Um,
no,
that guy goes to the gym and that's what you look like when you go to the gym.
That is real.
That's not just realistic.
That's real.
It's not unrealistic.
Some people don't want to look at other people that look good.
I read this article by a therapist who is saying like,
yeah,
that was the other one to lead.
You posted that dad bods are more attractive to women than rock hard abs survey
said they,
that survey said was in front of their fucking fat husbands.
100% said you use millionaires.
You know?
Then it's the Chris Pratt and Leonardo DiCaprio as well.
Chris Pratt is not have a dad bod.
He's sticking his stomach.
Guys been silly.
That guys jacked me.
I meet him in real life.
He's,
he's a stud.
Who's the other guy you know?
Caprio do you think the
dad bod,
you know like you hear this like usually you find out this way down the line,
but like some phenomenon society was like cooked up in a board room,
right?
Like,
for example,
let's say,
I dunno,
you made Twinkies and you realize like,
shit man,
people like really getting into this ketogenic diet and working out and there
could be a potential,
you probably have some AI saying like,
hey,
we've got like a health craze predicted for 2021 meaning twinkie sales are going
to drop by like 50% because guys don't want to go there,
don't want to be fat.
And so then you start disseminating into the world like,
all right,
let's come up with this thing.
What's a,
what's a way to call somebody out of shape but like to connect it to their
virility cause they're a dead dad bought yet dad bought.
So then he started getting it out there.
Like,
you know,
it helps if any product that is like bad for you kind of depends on two things.
One,
that it tastes fucking good and two,
that you can trick yourself into believing it's worth eating,
right?
Like it needs those two things.
Like,
in other words,
if there was like delicious uranium,
like some lunatic created like the sweetest,
most flavorful uranium biscuit,
you're not gonna eat that shit.
You know you're going to go to Chernobyl.
It's fucking all your stomach's gonna melt at the dinner table.
But if you could come up with like,
you know,
a nice Ipa like you were saying or some kind of thing that's,
oh it's just poison.
Basically it's going to destroy your liver over time.
It'll be a slow progression and you could like sink into alcoholism.
You know,
your personality will change and it'll be like nobody would do that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't even know what you're saying right now.
Go.
No one's going to do that.
Such a stupid premise.
No one's going to drink poison.
Slowly talk to Pfizer with her show.
Who would even do that shit,
man,
I would never do that.
I mean I drink cause I'm sophisticated and then like you did you by the way,
read that shit about how like hangovers or brain damage,
like when you have a hangover and you get better,
your brain hasn't recovered yet.
Just the part that you could sense has gotten better,
but the you have like physiological damage that's happening.
Of course.
Like when you read it you're like,
well Duh.
Of course it's fun.
It's fun to be drunk,
to be drawn to the problem.
It's fun to be drunk.
Oh my God.
It's fun to be lit if it lands joking.
Ah,
I mean that's one of the realities of any great thing is like it is a delight
and it is a beautiful part of life for many people,
but we at some point you just start tricking yourself.
I mean that's one of the things Mckenna I love that you said is like how history
has survived alcohol.
Like we managed to have that as our sacrament and still we have civilization.
Wow.
It's incredible because it didn't like it does turn people into fucking 28 days
later,
doesn't it?
When some low,
some people don't.
But it's really interesting when you consider his idea that at one point in time
there was psychedelic cultures that really didn't have our standard and
toxicants.
Right.
So they didn't have antidepressants,
they didn't have stimulants.
Yeah.
Unless it was something like coca leaves that they were eating right.
They didn't have processed cocaine,
but what they did have was copious amounts of psilocybin.
Yeah,
Liz surge acid than different plant forms.
There was like a bunch of different things with the Mayans used Iowasca DMT.
There was that a,
that shawman where they found his bag.
They've found it was like a 2000 years.
How many thousand years old?
2,500 years old.
Had DMT and yes.
Yeah.
It's like any fanny pack you find at burning man.
Probably the same ingredients.
Exactly.
Good.
Yeah,
it was a bit,
yeah.
That's hilarious.
I love when they find that shit out.
What do you got
that the DMT was in that a rabbit nose thing,
right?
Yeah.
The Fox knows.
Yes.
That was only a thousand years old.
I thought you were leading done to that 2,500 year old marijuana that just go.
Yeah,
that's true too.
That's a new one.
Yeah,
so people have been just getting blasted forever,
man.
Best.
Of course they have been.
As soon as they found it,
they were like,
why would I just go with regular life?
Yeah.
It's the vast,
it's,
it's so wonderful that that's being disseminated in a culture right now.
It's also people are decriminalizing it all over the place,
left and right.
It's slowly starting to happen.
Colorado first always boom,
they're on track now.
Oakland,
Oakland decriminalize it as a city.
They put it as the lowest priority.
All plant medicines including IOWASCA.
You saw AOC tweet.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
But she can't get traction.
Other people in Congress.
Like what?
Well,
it's hard.
It's hard to sell that bill.
It's hard to sell psychedelic research and you know,
maps has been doing amazing stuff with soldiers.
And you've been to the actual maps conference?
Yeah,
I have.
Yeah.
It was,
yeah.
It was wonderful because it's like these,
you know,
it's,
as much as I love hanging out with you and like my friends you take
psychedelics,
it's really inspiring to be around scientists who are sort of figuring out a way
to translate that experience into a data set that can convince legislators to
change draconian laws because they're doing the hard work.
You know,
you and I,
we get to go on and on and on about the multiverse and the DMT entities.
We can make things up,
we can make things out.
They can't,
it doesn't matter if they've taken it and had a real experience where some
advanced,
uh,
whatever you want to call it is a peer to them.
Whether they're a part of their subconscious or an alien and said,
listen,
here's what's going on.
We do this with every planet.
The first step is we've got to like undercut the hierarchical centralized power
structure.
And we know the only way to really do that is by teaching people that their
identities,
they think it is isn't quite right.
If we can expand the human identity,
selfishness goes away.
If we can get rid of the problem of trauma and people dealing with trauma by
being aggressive to the outside world,
then over time the circumference of the human identity expands beyond the
perimeters of me and into us.
And if that happens,
then we can like enter into like a type a civilization or whatever they call it,
the beginning of a global civilization.
But first we've got to get the fucking monkeys to climb down from the tree of
them,
their selfishness,
and if we can do that and get out,
we can lure a few people have it themselves just like getting a buggy out of the
tree so that like,
uh,
people are like,
wait a minute.
I don't think I'm just,
to me,
I think I'm in,
I'm connected.
Everything purely interconnected.
In fact,
I don't think I'm anything.
I think what I really am is the connection between me and others.
That's where I exist.
Not In this,
but you are something,
right?
Because you're very unique.
Like you personally are very unique when you're one of my favorite friends.
But you're also one of my weirdest friends.
I'll call you always talk,
dude,
you got to read this book.
It's like,
dude,
you gotta Watch this documentary and we will talk for hours about the crazy shit
over.
But you are very specific.
Like you're very,
I don't get the same conversation with Joey Diaz.
I don't get the same conversation if I call Ari.
Yeah.
Everybody has a different thing that they're also,
there's something going on that's uniquely you.
Oh yeah.
I mean it to say yeah cause otherwise you sinking denialism and you're like
imagine the point,
right.
That's not it at all.
It's that you don't exist in a vacuum.
It's like that's the main thing.
And to me like the fundamental problem right now is selfishness.
It's like when you're mad at someone on the interstate,
what did they do?
Something selfish.
When you're mad at someone in your life,
what did they do?
Something selfish.
When someone's mad at you,
what did you do?
Something selfish.
Almost always and like this is the reality is that selfishness is an innate
quality of being a human.
We are a self,
there is a sense of a self rather.
And we feel mixed up in it.
But the,
what you realize is like,
you know those fucking times where you authentically not because you're filming
it for your Instagram or whatever,
help somebody and you don't talk about it.
You just suddenly do it.
Not like giving someone money either,
but you get engaged with a person and you're there.
And then it's one of my favorite mushroom trips was when I started coming back
and I w before I really came down,
I started thinking like,
what was I doing?
I was doing something.
I was being so I was being a human.
I was being a fuck,
oh fuck,
I'm a human.
But for a second I wasn't a meat.
I had merged into something bigger than me.
Similarly,
if you just get really engaged in helping people,
you'll notice that for that amount of time you don't feel quite as shitty.
And it's not just because you're doing something good and there's some like
angel casting blessings on you.
It's because he got out of yourself for a second in the sense that you became
more than just you.
You are you and the person you were helping.
And that to me is like a really interesting uh,
aspect of where we're as a species is that the reality is man,
yeah,
we're all special and beautiful and wonderful,
but also you're not happening in a vacuum.
You're completely inexorably interconnected with everything and you can't get
out of that.
You're in it for real and the boundaries you've constructed around you and
whatever you think the rest of the world is there just in your head,
it's not real.
You made it up.
You told yourself a story and you believe that story so much like the poor
mother fuckers are getting into like the most psychotic cults.
You know,
where at the end of 10 years they reveal to you some crazy,
crazy shit beyond crazy.
You spent like $900,000 in this fucking thing and they're like,
yeah,
we all got shit out by woolly mammoths and now you have to feel like I'm fucking
either believe this and dive in or I'm like,
fuck,
I was wrong all this time.
Similarly,
most people have constructed this ridiculous armoring boundary around them based
on,
you know,
this is bad and this is good and that's not good and that's good and here I am
in the midst of it.
And that's a real painful situation to be in cause it's,
you have to fucking constantly exert that force field situation.
It's really,
I think why so many people are depressed and exhausted and can't really relax
because how can you relax if you're constantly in a state of creating an
imaginary barrier between you and infinity called yourself.
It's a really exhausting probably practice to be engaged in.
And then there's some people who impose themselves on other people.
They make their life and their problems.
100% of the focus of this other person.
So that person becomes an enabler.
You see that with husbands and wives sometimes or even with friends,
like one person as the active asshole.
Then the other person is the fixer up or man Mike fucked up again.
I got to go get him
active.
Yeah.
Asshole centralization man.
And it's like our whole firm,
like our family structures usually to like the entire way we run our government
is usually centralized around one key identity and that we,
and you know,
we,
we've had this conversation many times on the show,
which I like the preposterous nature of a king,
of president,
of pope a bishop,
a world leader or a teacher,
whatever the fuck it is,
it's preposterous.
And uh,
it's also quite dangerous,
you know,
because it's like not only did we have the situation of the parasitic friend,
but even worse,
you can get into the situation of the carets Madec friend who's tricking you
into doing some into the idea that you could do something called cosmic
hitchhiking.
That's what Chogyam Trungpa calls it,
which is basically the idea that like,
I'm going to use you because you are so great and you will be the thing that
helps me become a real person.
It's another person.
One.
Yeah,
the chosen ones.
You are our teacher.
We worship you.
Oh,
home show is the way that I had been born.
The Dalai Lama.
So from the jump,
you're something special.
You're the chosen one and the one either reincarnation of who will this supposed
to be?
Are there a Toku?
That's what it's called.
So it's the Tohoku system and the way it would work would be,
you know,
cause you have to,
like,
if you look at the history of Tibet,
it was called the hermit kingdom and it was closed off from the rest of the
world.
It's very hard to get in there.
Seven years in Tibet is about somebody you made it through and became friends
with the Dalai Lama as a kid.
Um,
anyway,
so within the system,
uh,
there is this idea that,
beings reincarnate and that if you're awakened enough,
if you're like really like it,
the sort of last phase of this sort of,
uh,
what would you call it?
The cycle you were talking about earlier,
then you stop losing at least some of the Amnesia that happens when you get
processed through the liminal inbetween period called the Bardo between this
incarnation and the next.
So anyway,
they go to children,
they put in front of them the,
uh,
particular,
items that belonged to the previous incarnation that they think they are
Oracle's vision visionaries bring the monks to a particular village and then the
kid picks it and then that big kid becomes the next,
this or that.
It's called a Tokyo.
How many kids?
They looked at a,
I don't know man.
I don't know the depths of it get turns out to be an asshole.
I take his powers away.
Well,
I think it has happened where told boozer like it's similar to like a,
what the fuck is the,
what is the thing where those kids get one summer to go?
Like the summer of fucking,
what does that really show?
Yeah,
that's almost,
that's a rumples bring a rub sprayer.
Yeah.
Rover.
I'm sorry,
what does that,
there's a great documentary on that.
Yeah,
something,
the devil's something.
The devil.
So it's like a great name,
the devil summer,
but it's just like the devil's playground.
[inaudible]
fuck.
And the smoke.
And then a lot of them come back.
Well,
what feel empty?
I believe that was one of the ways they studied the impact of Mtma wasn't it by
like cause like these,
like if you find someone who's taken Mtma but no other drug,
it's pretty rare.
So you need to find a person who's only taken MTMA otherwise he can't acts like
assess that there's some cognitive damage.
Cause it could've been the acid,
it could have been the mushrooms,
it could've been the time you fell on your ass when you were hammered.
Who the fuck knows?
But these kids,
some of them have only taken MTMA and so I believe that they use them as a
sample to like determine if there was any kind of neurological damage caused by
the drug itself.
But so I think it's similar phenomena happens within that system where some kids
are like,
I'm not a reincarnated beating,
I'm a musician.
I want to go play
music.
And they leave.
Do you know who's a musician who's also reincarnated being Jimi Hendrix?
Steven Seagal?
What?
Yup.
When did that happen?
I didn't know that.
Told them.
I think the Dalai Lama might've hooked him up,
told them.
I'm like one of those guys over there and told them that he was the
reincarnation of a,
someone's super special.
Jesus.
God,
it's a big deal over there.
Well then they had a ceremony and everything.
Oh it is from 1997 this is the long written thing and bio about it.
Oh,
that's a lot of words.
I know that's going to breed that.
The recognition of Steven Seagal as a reincarnation of the treasure revealer
Chung drag door Jay.
Wow.
Of that sale pile.
You'll monastery.
Yeah.
So He's a reincarnation.
Well that's comforting to know.
He's always been with us,
you know,
cause it's like one of the things that does bother me is to imagine a world
without Seagal,
you know?
So it's cool to know he's always been here,
coming back again and again.
How come nobody was ever a loser in a past life?
Oh,
but he was always a fucking nope.
Awesome.
Oh,
you mean,
oh right.
Yeah.
When I went a little full of shit people.
Yeah,
of course.
Like what are you going to be like 30 you know what?
If you're making money as a fucking psychic and you're like,
Whoa,
you are basically like a gutter rat.
You are,
you've only been a rat.
You can filth.
You weren't even,
you are a mucus thing.
Like I'm not sure what you call it,
a kind of jellyfish that killed babies.
You're a tapeworm,
you're one of those long worms that went into someone's brain and sure
stenosis motherfucker,
you're uncooked pork.
You are a math.
You are.
Yeah.
The whole like to me like the whole reincarnation is a toll.
Cool.
Yeah.
I told you it's a statement from the guy.
I'm recognized.
My students,
Steven Seagal as a reincarnation Toku of the treasure revealer Chung drag door.
Jay,
this has been some confusion.
Uncertainty as to what this means.
I'm writing to clarify the situation.
No clarifying necessary.
I'll see you later man.
I gotta go.
I might be full of Shit.
You are galls got five hookers going to this guy's house right now as we speak.
Well also the other there,
so there's talk of like ending the Tohoku system and um,
the Dalai Lama has even said that.
And,
uh,
recognizing that cause what's cool,
it's all right.
Well I'm,
uh,
among many things is that he said,
you know,
if sa he's very rational and he said,
if science proves something in Buddhism is off,
we'll change Buddhism to fit the rational mind.
And that's the beauty of Buddhism.
There's pageantry in it,
there's ceremony,
there's ritual in it.
Just like any other religion.
It's beautiful.
Personally,
I think that there is a sort of,
uh,
area of,
experience accessible through their practices that I guess could best be
compared to psychedelics or something like that.
But,
uh,
to me what I love about it is all the pageantry aside and all of it aside.
It's not faith based.
It's a very basic
series of ideas that you have to digest.
You have to think about,
you have to look into,
you don't just get to be it.
It's like,
you know,
maybe some forms of it.
There could be an example of that.
But in general it's more along the lines of here's the basic fundamental
principles behind this not and the co and the cording of a human life than we've
discovered.
Here's where some sufferings coming from all the suffering in fact,
and here's how to fix it.
That's the four noble truths of Buddhism and that just hearing it,
who gives a fuck?
You could here,
life is suffering.
The cause of suffering is attachment.
Get rid of attachment.
Suffering ends.
Here's the system to get rid of attachment and you know,
whatever life is suffering was I even fucking mean.
What does life of even mean?
What does it even mean by suffering this,
this first noble truth,
it gets completely miss translated anyway,
Duca,
it means wobbly wheel.
It's more akin to like if you're riding a bike that's got not enough air in it,
it's going to be a rough ride,
but it's going to be even more of a rough ride.
If you have some out,
trick yourself into thinking there's enough air in the tire so that anytime you
hit some bumps you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
What I mean,
that's it.
That's it.
It's like wobbly wheel.
The things wonky.
You think you're not going to get this connected when you've been on the line
with Verizon for an hour,
you're going to get disconnected.
It tends to happen.
You're going to get cut off in traffic,
you're gonna fail.
You're going to be disappointed.
This is reality.
But somehow you've imagined that it doesn't work like that.
And every single time you're met with the truth,
you're like,
ah,
Oh God,
this sucks.
And you know,
so that's gonna.
That creates a lot of problems and it creates to some ways to deal with it,
which is desire and aversion.
So you're somewhere and you want to be somewhere else,
basically.
You know,
you're,
you're somewhere and you're like,
I don't want to be in this place.
Or you know,
you're imagining that if you get this thing or that thing,
the pain you're feeling is of the wobbly wheel will go away.
Do the experiment,
see if it's true.
See if it's true.
That's all you can do is like really look at the shit that you want.
Like I could come home and mow,
could pulled up and given me seven mogue ones.
Right?
And I'm going to sit and play those fucking mogue ones for weeks and weeks until
I'm sweaty and smell like fucking just someone shoved a Salami under the balls
of an ape.
You know,
I'm not going to take showers
using it.
Stink in like probably weeping into the mug and sneezing into it.
Anyway,
the point is eventually after I saw the distraction has gone away,
I'm going to return to my fundamental self.
You know,
Eh,
the fundamental condition of existence as it is regardless.
And so this is sort of the print,
some of the principles,
I understand it,
which you're really quite intelligent,
you know,
it's really,
and,
and what I love about it most of all is there's always this invitation,
which is go see,
go see.
It's not because I'm telling you this,
believe it,
right?
It's like go see,
maybe it's different for you and,
and,
but you need to go check.
Like every time you're doing the thing that you've been repeating over and over
again,
is it making you happy for real?
Is it really working?
Is it working?
And if it's working,
great,
but if it's not and you're trying to pretend it is because you've been doing it
so long,
well who are you?
Who's winning this game of self deception?
What?
What,
what?
There's no winning.
If the game is tricking yourself,
you can only what and what do you do?
Like how do you feel about life if you're always tricking yourself?
Hey Twitter world.
Yeah man,
that's right.
You will only feel that the everyone is trying to trick you and you'll feel like
there's a grand conspiracy and you'll feel like the world's out to get you and
there is a greater good gets seat,
which is that you are running a game on yourself.
Yeah.
I feel like we should end with that.
I
fell like that's very important for people to hear.
Yeah,
I true and thinking resonates with all of us.
We've all done that at the lowest points of consciousness in your life.
He run a little trick on yourself or to get past things work,
you know?
And I think in some of that trick is run because you don't totally understand
who you are.
And you want to,
maybe I'm this guy,
maybe I'm,
maybe I'm a hardcore Republican.
Hey,
you know what?
Those fucking Democrats,
they tricked me for far too long.
I'm over here now.
Yeah.
I found my home,
found my home over here,
and that's one of the things that people do.
They really do.
They hop from it.
I used to be a Vegan,
but now I'm a fucking corner.
This time I just see all stakes.
Ribeye steaks all day long.
You know what?
I couldn't believe what a pussy I was when I was just eating vegetables.
Congrats.
That's a lot of it,
right?
Yeah,
man.
And it's,
and it's almost exactly like what we were talking about with religions that you
looked down these grids,
these grids are run by different operating systems that require different
behavior from their women.
This operating system,
you can't drive.
You gotta dress like a beekeeper and you have to do this and you have to do
that.
This operating system,
you put a plate through your lip and yeah,
you got a bone in your nose and this and this operating system,
everybody gets face tattoos.
And this operating system,
you know,
and no one needs peak,
uh,
pork.
It's another,
Oh God does not want in our operating system.
You get the same thing I think with right and left with Vegan and eater with a
pick your poison,
like whatever the fuck it is.
Yeah,
whatever thing it is that you're into.
Especially ideological,
especially lifestyle based,
there's always a,
an opposing one,
like the people that don't want people to be gay or the people that even a lot
of the abortion stuff,
a lot of the abortion stuff,
it's like how of it is how much of this really well thought out behavior and how
much of it is,
how does your tribe respond to this?
And one of the ways you can tell,
especially if you're talking to a hardcore lefty or a Republican for that
matter,
we can offer two examples,
but one of the ways he could tell his hard core lefties do not like to discuss
late term abortion.
He said,
well what if it's a fetus?
What if it's a baby?
What if,
what if we're talking like eight months in and it's a woman's right to choose.
It's a women's right?
No,
it's,
it's a baby in this person's body like when is it a baby?
Look,
I'm a hundred percent pro women's right to choose.
I'm a hundred percent pro choice,
but late term abortions are fucking weird.
It's dark.
It's strange and everybody knows that.
Everybody knows that.
But if you're a hardcore lefty,
you won't say it.
And then the hardcore righties,
what if you were raped?
What if you're,
what if you're a little girl,
a 13 year old girl,
she was raped.
Do you want that girl to carry your fucking baby?
Are you crazy?
She was raped four weeks ago.
We found out she's pregnant.
What do you want me to do?
You want me to pray?
How about fuck you right?
How about fuck you might raped little girl is not going to have to carry
someone's baby fucking Asshole,
right?
The idea that your invisible man in the sky that watches over everything you do
but allows rape to occur,
allows little kids to get raped.
You want that little kid to carry a baby,
I'll fucking kill you.
Right?
Your goddamn crazy.
There's people that feel like that too.
Well,
this is,
if you want to find the column commonality,
the common thread.
It's just the way you were describing,
which is a natural reaction to someone saying that to you are controlling your
life in that way.
It's aggression.
So like on both sides.
Yeah.
It's not that there's an articulation of a point of view.
It's at the point of view is being flavored with anger.
With aggression.
Yes.
Pushing,
pushing,
pushing.
It's a woman's right to choose.
Yeah.
And it's,
or it's not,
or whatever.
Both sides have with them.
A quality of aggression.
Yep.
So this is like,
this is,
you know,
not to over simplify things.
The reality is,
man,
we won.
We got to cut ourselves a break.
And you know this and you've articulated as better than anybody.
We weren't.
We were monkeys not that long ago.
Really recent.
Go look at monkeys,
see how they act.
Crazy.
Right?
So give number one,
give yourself a fucking break.
You and the evolutionary,
like from the evolutionary perspective,
you're just barely waking up.
But because you've been a monkey inside of you,
there's some serious,
serious aggression because that was the way to deal with the eagle that was
bigger than you,
that carried your wife away to feed doings and chicks.
You weren't going to fucking have a sit down with the Eagle and be like,
listen,
I know you need to live.
And my wife,
I imagined she was delicious.
We've,
I've been,
you know,
farming for the last several years and feeding her every day and you know,
the baby's going to die because he was drinking your milk and all legal.
But listen,
I wonder if maybe you could just spare the rest of my family.
What are you're going to do is kill that fucking eagle anyway,
you can fire spears,
whatever.
So now to think that that has gone away,
it's very similar to a person who takes a vacation and suddenly realizes I can't
relax,
will you can't relax.
Because for the last fucking year,
you've been going nonstop in a state of constant stress,
freaking out.
You're on vacation.
You think that momentum is going to go away?
No,
it's just going to be more apparent.
So you're going to like,
wow,
I've got guzzle it down and try to fuck it away.
But then you're on the airplane hung over and it's like,
you know what I mean?
You're all fucking over.
And it's like,
what happened though was vacation is already over.
That's what has happened to us,
which is like,
listen,
we've got a good right now.
But it wasn't that long ago that saber tooth tigers were dragging our children
to the fucking jungle and eating them.
And we find sh feet that were our kids' feet in a Bush somewhere.
And this traumas in US epigenetically.
So anyway,
the point is,
give yourself a fucking break.
But the other point is that being said,
we recognize you're being aggressive.
You're approach using anger and intolerance,
uh,
is not working.
It's money as noble as your purpose may be.
You want a global civilization of joy.
Whatever the fuck it is,
it's not working.
If you're using the exact same momentum that causes the wars that you're hoping
to stop.
So the first step has to be I think an internal personal exploration to create
some,
not to even get rid of the aggression.
It'd be like I'm bad because I'm angry or I'm all that bullshit.
But to create some,
to find out what is the circumference of the self.
And then within that you realize the thing you thought was all of you that
coiled up fucking anger is in fact a tiny piece of you.
It's still there and it's still useful at times,
but it's not all of you.
And because the circumference is widened the next time the angry part of you
starts bubbling.
It's just like,
it's the difference between somebody throwing a brick and a bathtub and a brick
in the ocean.
It's like a brick in the ocean.
No big deal.
A brick in the bathtub.
Fuck you dude,
Chris and my best fits you the fuck out.
So that's,
that's the idea is like we're not trying to annihilate the self or our say this,
this person,
this human being you are,
it's irrelevant or it's not worth this or that.
It's just what is the circumference of your identity.
And that's the exploration I think that gets,
that Buddhism invites people to do or any religion that is real and good.
It's inviting people like find out what you are.
And then as a natural byproduct of that exploration,
you become a little more gentle.
And because you're gentle,
you're more effective.
That's where it gets really weird.
Gentleness seems to be quite often the,
what was my friend saying?
He's like,
you know,
if my dogs are outside and I'm like,
get the fuck,
I thought fuck it.
House,
they're not coming in.
But if I'm like,
come on,
I love you and you really mean it.
They come running into house.
Yeah.
So this is the thing is like it,
the aggression stuff,
it worked man.
Cause of the eagles and the Tigers and all that shit.
But you know what I mean?
Now maybe there's a new way.
Yeah.
And we're stuck.
We're stuck with the DNA that sort of goes through how to survive.
Yeah.
Rules and the Tigers that we needed it.
We needed it
bit,
you know,
don't like,
or a violet or something like,
in fact,
love it.
I think that's part of the appeal of the Dad bod part of the appeal of like,
you know,
someone talking about unrealistic body expectations.
You're really talking about like less reliance on the,
the flesh,
the,
the virility,
the athletic ability,
the ability to conquer,
you know,
the ability to,
to breed and spread your genes and fight off predators and enemies and invaders.
It's not nearly as necessary as it used to be,
but necessary but necessary.
And,
but the people who are not capable of it despise it because they think it's the
problem.
They think the ability to conquer is the problem.
Yeah,
the strong.
And if everyone was weak,
it's essentially the argument for socialism,
you know?
Oh,
you don't have it.
If you don't have it and you see other people have it.
Like I only anybody should have it.
How about that?
Oh yeah.
And it's also part of it.
I mean,
people have encountered,
the thing is,
is like take a person who has some chip on their shoulder about dudes with
muscles.
Right?
If you look at it,
that didn't happen by itself.
They didn't,
weren't,
didn't wake up one day and like I fucking hate biceps.
What happened is like people with muscles who were traditionally like ideally
war like meant to be warriors and protectors in a noble way.
They've gotten really aggressive like you see and it's not all of them,
but how many videos have popped up,
have,
you know,
a police officer,
I'll blow your fucking head off,
get the fuck.
Cause the kid took a doll,
you know that video we were talking about?
Yes.
So it's like,
so,
so similarly,
like sometimes what's coinciding with the muscular thing is also a dominant
aggressive attitude to the two have become mixed together.
The conflate them.
Yes.
And it's theirs.
They're there.
If you've ever been around people who are real fighters,
usually they're like the most gentle people you've ever met.
Super Nice people.
And it's unnerving because you know,
like Eddie Bravo,
he's a nice man.
You when I'm around him,
like I forget that I could just suddenly be dead.
You know that.
I mean if you didn't forget it,
you'd be nervous around him all the time.
Like,
you know,
you're in a great conversation with them and join his company and then like you
could just,
that's it.
So similarly like,
uh,
this is what happened.
That,
so the idea is like,
you've got a continuum of possible ways that humans express themselves.
On one side,
you have the condition of the noble warrior,
which is a train discipline person who's literally putting themselves in front
of others.
The Samurai,
you talk about it a bunch,
you know,
who's fading into the background,
who doesn't even give a fuck if anybody knows I did anything heroic because
they've given up on that.
It's a very spiritual way of being.
Well then there's also the concern about the warmonger,
like why does the warmonger exists?
Is the warmonger like the firefighter that starts their own fires.
I a lot of the times,
yes,
they live for that.
They live for that experience because that's what they desire.
Yeah.
If you,
if you,
if you want to sell umbrellas,
you need it to rain.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
But this is again,
corruption of,
uh,
of,
of a potential ideal,
which is like,
regardless of the fact that we've all kind of like witnessed various examples in
pretty much every profession of what it looks like when things aren't so great
and imbalanced.
There's also examples of people who are the opposite of that,
who are like completely,
you know,
in service who like,
how many firemen got fucking incinerated in September 11th man,
you know,
and the truth is,
I can't name,
unfortunately,
embarrassingly enough,
I couldn't name one of them if you pay me too.
These are people who literally gave their entire life up,
who went up that fucking thing.
They didn't think they were coming back down.
There are firemen.
They looked at that and they were probably like,
yeah,
I'm going to die.
I Bet I died today.
But they're like,
if I don't do it,
well no one does it.
So that's an example of how good it can be and why we need it and what it can
really be.
That's a sacred way to be.
And the exact same is true for pretty much every profession.
And yet when aggression gets in there,
it fucks it up.
It's sours,
it imbalances it,
and it's like ultimately completely ineffective,
you know?
And it's also another version of selfishness.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
What we talking about before being the problem,
the real problem with the naked aggressive behavior,
naked aggression,
meaning unprovoked aggression,
is that it's entirely selfish.
Like,
I want what you have.
I take,
I conquer.
Yeah.
That,
that is selfishness and it's worse,
most primal form.
That's right.
And on that note,
we're gonna wrap this bitch up doc and draws all,
you're the fucking,
yeah,
you're the man.
Thanks for having me better,
man.
We need to do this more often that we always say this,
and let's do a shrimp raid two.
Where's Chris?
Ryan is driving that fucking van around the world.
Chris Ryan is going to come back here.
Enlightened every really well.
I look at his page.
Every picture he is getting further and further out in the woods.
I love you buddy.
I love you too.
Bye everybody.